Dr. Jordan B. Peterson, an evening to transform your life. If you say the truth and nothing else, you'll have an immense adventure as a consequence. You won't know what's going to happen to you, but the truth will reveal the world the way it's intended to be revealed, and the consequence for you will be that you'll have the adventure of your life. Live at Scotiabank Arena, March 6th. Get tickets now at libnation.com. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off
乔丹·B·彼得森博士，一个改变你人生的夜晚。如果你只说真话，不掺杂其他，你的人生将因此开启一场宏大的冒险。你无法预知会发生什么，但真相会以其本来的面目揭示这个世界，而你将收获一场终生难忘的冒险。3月6日，斯科舍银行球馆现场直播。立即前往libnation.com购票。使用Fizz忠诚度计划，只需拥有移动套餐即可获得奖励。你知道的，就是发短信之类的。如果你还没有通过移动套餐获得额外流量和现金抵扣等奖励，
with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. It was getting late on Tuesday October 15 1946 when 16 year old Ruth Smock was startled by the sound of a screen door creaking behind her. Ruth had recently moved into a rooming house in Fort Scott, Kansas to attend a larger high school that offered more varied classes than the one in her rural Missouri hometown.
那你用的就不是Fizz。今天就切换吧。适用相关条款。详情请见fizz.ca。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用内或我们网站上本集节目的说明。1946年10月15日星期二，天色渐晚，16岁的露丝·斯莫克被身后纱门吱呀作响的声音惊醒。露丝最近搬进了堪萨斯州斯科特堡的一间出租屋，以便就读一所比她密苏里州家乡那所学校提供更多样化课程的高中。
Living in the city also allowed Ruth to work part time as a telephone operator for Southwestern Bell so she could save some money. The problem was, Ruth lived alone and she wasn't expecting any visitors that evening. A chilling realisation quickly set in. She had left the front door unlocked after returning home from the grocery store earlier. An unfamiliar man was now standing in her apartment. The man was tall, appeared to be in his 50s, and was dressed in dirty bib overalls, the kind typically worn by farmers. He greeted Ruth casually, saying, hi sis, before reaching for a wall switch and turning off the lights.
住在城里也让露丝有机会在西南贝尔公司兼职做电话接线员，这样她就能存点钱。问题是，露丝独自居住，那天晚上她并没有预期会有访客。一种令人不寒而栗的念头迅速涌上心头。她早些时候从杂货店回家后，忘了锁前门。一个陌生的男人现在正站在她的公寓里。那男人个子很高，看起来50多岁，穿着脏兮兮的背带裤，那是农民通常穿的那种。他随意地向露丝打招呼，说了声“嗨，小妹”，然后伸手去够墙上的开关，关掉了灯。
Moving quickly, the stranger grabbed Ruth and tore at her clothes. She fought back and managed to press her thumbs into his eyes. This only enraged him further. "'I'll fix you so no one will look at you again,' he threatened, shoving a rag against Ruth's face. Ruth felt herself growing dizzy and drowsy. Her vision blurred. The last thing she saw before her eyes closed completely was the man heating a flat iron on the kitchen stove. By the time Ruth regained consciousness, it was seven thirty the next morning. She was sprawled on the kitchen floor, her clothes torn with cuts and scratches across her legs, neck, and face. These wounds were superficial, unlike the injuries to her thighs.
陌生人迅速行动，抓住露丝并撕扯她的衣服。她奋力反抗，设法用拇指戳向他的眼睛。这反而激怒了他。“‘我要让你变得没人再想看你一眼，’”他威胁道，并把一块抹布塞在露丝脸上。露丝感到一阵头晕目眩，昏昏欲睡。她的视线变得模糊。在双眼完全闭上之前，她看到的最后一幕是那个男人正在厨房炉灶上加热一把平底熨斗。当露丝恢复意识时，已经是第二天早上七点半了。她瘫倒在厨房地板上，衣服被撕破，腿部、颈部和脸上满是割伤和抓痕。这些伤口都很浅，与她大腿上的伤势不同。
Both of Ruth's legs bore painful first-degree burns, which had been branded onto her flesh by the flatiron. Ruth stayed silent on the floor until she was sure her attacker was no longer there. She then called her parents, who contacted the police. They deduced that Ruth's attacker had soaked the rag he pressed to her face with chloroform, a sweet smelling anesthetic, before burning her legs while she lay unconscious. Although a physician confirmed that Ruth hadn't been raped, police were certain the crime was sexually motivated. Ruth was brought to her parents' home to recover but later moved in with a family friend as the thought of staying in her apartment overwhelms her with such intense dread
露丝的双腿都有痛苦的一级烧伤，那是被平底熨斗烙在肉上的。露丝在地板上保持沉默，直到确定袭击者已经离开。随后她给父母打了电话，父母联系了警察。他们推断，露丝的袭击者在把抹布按在她脸上之前，用氯仿（一种气味甜美的麻醉剂）浸湿了抹布，然后在她昏迷时烧伤了她的腿。尽管医生证实露丝没有被强奸，但警方确信这起犯罪具有性动机。露丝被带回父母家休养，但后来搬去与一位家庭朋友同住，因为想到要待在自己的公寓里，她就感到一种强烈的恐惧，
that it made her physically ill. Meanwhile, the violent incident made the local newspapers as authorities worked to identify the man responsible. By 1977, 31 years had passed since Ruth Smock was attacked. 47-year-old Ruth now went by the last name Finley after marrying her high school sweetheart, 49-year-old Ed. The Finleys lived in a modest, single-storey wood-frame house on a dead-end street in Wichita, Kansas, 150 miles west of Fort Scott. One warm June afternoon, Ed was taking a break from building a patio in the backyard when he suddenly collapsed. Ruth frantically called for an ambulance and Ed was rushed to the hospital, where he regained consciousness in the emergency department. It was initially thought that Ed had suffered a heart attack due to the strenuous outdoor work,
以至于让她身体不适。与此同时，这起暴力事件登上了当地报纸，当局正努力查明肇事者的身份。到1977年，距离露丝·斯莫克遇袭已经过去了31年。47岁的露丝在嫁给高中恋人、49岁的埃德后，改姓芬利。芬利夫妇住在堪萨斯州威奇托市一条死胡同里的一栋朴素的单层木结构房子里，距离斯科特堡以西150英里。一个温暖的六月午后，埃德正在后院休息，没盖露台，突然晕倒了。露丝惊慌失措地叫了救护车，埃德被紧急送往医院，并在急诊室恢复了意识。起初人们认为埃德是因为户外劳累过度而心脏病发作，
but doctors kept him overnight for further tests to make an official diagnosis. In the meantime, Ruth returned home alone, overwhelmed at the thought of almost losing her husband. She called the couple's two adult sons, as well as other family and friends, to update them on his condition. As the night wore on, Ruth anxiously waited for an update from the hospital. She kept herself occupied with the television and radio, but this only made her anxiety worse. A serial killer had been targeting women in Kansas, and the media was obsessed with reporting on the lurid details of his crimes, which involved breaking into victims' homes and committing
但医生让他留院观察过夜，以便进行进一步检查并做出正式诊断。在此期间，露丝独自回到家中，想到差点失去丈夫，她感到心力交瘁。她给夫妇俩的两个成年儿子以及其他亲友打了电话，告知他们埃德的情况。随着夜色渐深，露丝焦急地等待着医院的消息。她一直用电视和广播来打发时间，但这只会让她的焦虑加剧。一名连环杀手一直在堪萨斯州针对女性作案，媒体沉迷于报道他罪行的耸人听闻的细节，这些罪行包括闯入受害者家中并实施
gruesome acts of sexualised violence. Being home alone at night did little to calm Ruth's nerves. Every creak and crack she heard only heightened her unease. Then, at around 10.30pm, the phone rang. When Ruth answered, a male voice on the other line asked, is this Ruth Smock from Fort Scott, Kansas? The question struck her as odd. Ruth had been married since 1950, and few people in her life knew her maiden name. The only connection she still had to her past in Fort Scott was her ongoing employment with South Western Bell, though she now worked as a secretary in the company's Wichita office. Assuming the caller was an old acquaintance, Ruth confirmed her identity.
令人毛骨悚然的性暴力行为。独自在家过夜并不能缓解露丝的紧张情绪。她听到的每一次吱呀声和裂缝声都加剧了她的不安。然后，大约晚上10点30分，电话响了。当露丝接听时，电话那头传来一个男人的声音，问道：“你是堪萨斯州斯科特堡的露丝·斯莫克吗？”这个问题让她觉得很奇怪。露丝自1950年结婚以来一直使用夫姓，生活中很少有人知道她的娘家姓。她与斯科特堡过去的唯一联系就是她目前在西南贝尔公司的工作，尽管她现在在公司威奇托分部担任秘书。露丝以为打电话的是一位老相识，便确认了自己的身份。
The man began asking about her past, specifically the rooming house she had lived in when she was sixteen. He then asked cryptically, do you still wear your brands? Feeling uneasy about his intrusive questions, Ruth cautiously gave vague answers. This irritated the caller, who snapped, look, I know all about that night. Confused, Ruth replied, I don't know what you're talking about. The man then read out what sounded like a newspaper article. Branded on both thighs by a hot flat iron, Ruth Smock, 16 year old Fort Scott High School girl, was resting today at the home of her parents following an attack upon her early last night by a man police called a sex maniac. The caller continued recounting the violent assault against Ruth from over 30 years
那男人开始询问她的过去，特别是她16岁时住过的那间出租屋。然后他含糊其辞地问：“你还留着你的烙印吗？”露丝对这些侵入性的问题感到不安，谨慎地给出了模糊的回答。这激怒了打电话的人，他厉声说道：“听着，我对那天晚上的事了如指掌。”露丝困惑地回答：“我不知道你在说什么。”随后，那男人读出了一段听起来像是报纸文章的内容。“双腿被热平底熨斗烙伤，16岁的斯科特堡高中女生露丝·斯莫克，在昨晚早些时候遭到一名被警方称为‘性狂人’的男子袭击后，今天正在父母家中休养。”打电话的人继续讲述着30多年前针对露丝的那场暴力袭击。
earlier. While Ruth's physical wounds from that night had healed, the case had never been solved. She had pushed the terrifying experience to the back of her mind, choosing to move forward with her life. It wasn't something she discussed with anyone, not even her sons knew about it. The caller explained that he worked for a construction company and had recently discovered a stack of old newspapers while demolishing a building in Fort Scott. He claimed he'd found embarrassing stories about three people and planned to call them all, starting with Ruth. The caller told Ruth he knew where she lived and worked, and threatened to leave a copy of the article about her attack where everyone in her life could see it.
虽然露丝那晚受到的身体创伤已经愈合，但案件从未破获。她把那次可怕的经历压在心底，选择继续生活。这不是她与任何人讨论过的事情，甚至连她的儿子们都不知道。打电话的人解释说他在一家建筑公司工作，最近在拆除斯科特堡的一栋建筑时发现了一堆旧报纸。他声称自己发现了关于三个人的尴尬故事，并计划给他们每个人打电话，从露丝开始。打电话的人告诉露丝，他知道她住在哪里、在哪里工作，并威胁要把关于她遇袭的文章副本留在她生活圈中每个人都能看到的地方。
However, he said he'd reconsider if Ruth sent him money. At that point, Ruth hung up the phone. The strange call left Ruth shaken. Not only did it force her to confront a part of her past she had long since buried, she feared the man trying to extort her might show up at her house to confront her in person. Yet the night passed without incident, and the next morning Ruth visited her husband in the hospital. By then, Ed's sudden collapse had been linked to an untreated injury from a car accident the previous year. Although Ruth was relieved to learn that Ed's heart was healthy, he remained in the hospital for several more days to recover. Meanwhile, Ruth nervously waited to see if the extorter would contact her again, but he didn't.
然而，他说如果露丝给他钱，他会重新考虑。在那一刻，露丝挂断了电话。这通奇怪的电话让露丝心神不宁。它不仅迫使她面对自己早已埋葬的过去，她还担心那个试图勒索她的人可能会出现在她家门口当面与她对质。然而，那一晚平安无事，第二天早上露丝去医院探望了丈夫。到那时，埃德的突然晕倒已被证实与前一年车祸中未治愈的伤势有关。虽然得知埃德心脏健康让露丝松了一口气，但他仍需在医院多住几天以恢复健康。与此同时，露丝紧张地等待着勒索者是否会再次联系她，但他没有。
By the time Ed returned home, life for the Finleys returned to normal. Ruth didn't tell Ed about the caller, choosing to act as though nothing had ever happened. Less than a month later, in early July, Ruth was sitting in her office at South Western Bell going through her Daily Mail when she came across a peculiar brown envelope. Her name was written on it in childlike handwriting, but there was no address. Ruth realised the envelope must have been hand delivered as there was no way it could have made it to her through the postal system without an address printed on it. Inside was a yellowed newspaper clipping from the Fort Scott Tribune. It was the same article detailing the 1946 attack on teenage Ruth that the anonymous caller had
当埃德回到家时，芬利一家的生活恢复了正常。露丝没有告诉埃德关于打电话人的事，选择表现得好像什么都没发生过一样。不到一个月后，7月初，露丝坐在西南贝尔公司的办公室里处理日常邮件时，发现了一个奇怪的棕色信封。上面用孩子气的笔迹写着她的名字，但没有地址。露丝意识到信封一定是亲手送达的，因为如果没有打印地址，它不可能通过邮政系统送到她手中。里面是一张发黄的《斯科特堡论坛报》剪报。正是那个匿名打电话的人几周前读给她的、详细描述1946年少女露丝遇袭的文章。
read to her weeks before. Startled, Ruth tore up the article and threw it in the trash. Ruth's parents had raised her to be self-reliant, instilling in her the belief that emotions should be repressed and personal problems handled privately. As a result, Ruth chose not to tell Ed about the harassment. Over the following months, the man called the Finlay home six more times. As soon as Ruth recognised his voice, she hung up immediately. Occasionally, Ed answered the phone, only to hear a dial tone. He assumed they were being pranked by mischievous children. Ruth kept the truth secret, along with the fact that her chronic headaches were getting worse. She just hoped the stranger would leave her alone once he realised she wasn't willing
露丝大吃一惊，撕碎了文章扔进了垃圾桶。露丝的父母从小教育她要自立，向她灌输了情绪应该压抑、个人问题应私下处理的信念。因此，露丝选择不告诉埃德关于骚扰的事。在接下来的几个月里，那个男人又给芬利家打了六次电话。露丝一听出他的声音，就立即挂断。偶尔埃德接电话，却只听到拨号音。他以为是顽皮的孩子在恶作剧。露丝保守着真相，以及她慢性头痛日益加重的事实。她只是希望那个陌生人在意识到她不愿与他纠缠后会放过她。
to engage with him. By August, two months had passed since the anonymous caller first contacted Ruth. She was walking the streets of downtown Wichita after finishing work for the day, waiting for Ed's shift to end so they could carpool home together. As she crossed the road at the corner of Broadway and Douglas, a male voice suddenly said, "'You've done a good job at work this week. You can take the weekend off.'" Ruth realised the comment was directed at her. It had come from a stranger who was walking alongside her. He was tall, lean and appeared to be in his late forties with brown eyes and black
到了8月，距离匿名者第一次联系露丝已经过去了两个月。她下班后走在威奇托市中心的街道上，等着埃德下班，这样他们可以一起拼车回家。当她穿过百老汇和道格拉斯街角时，一个男人的声音突然说：“你这周工作表现不错。你可以周末休息。”露丝意识到这话是对她说的。声音来自一个走在她身边的陌生人。他身材高大、瘦削，看起来40多岁，棕色的眼睛，黑色的头发开始变灰。他看起来无害，穿着牛仔裤、格子衬衫和白色网球鞋。那男人试图与露丝闲聊，但她不感兴趣，几乎没理他。他不为所动，保持着步伐，问题变得越来越尖锐。“你在电话公司工作，对吧？”尽管露丝表现出明显的冷淡，他还是继续追问。“你在那里做什么？你是接线员吗？”露丝保持沉默，那男人喋喋不休地谈论着他对拉斯维加斯赌博的热爱，甚至邀请她有空和他一起去旅行。然后他开始谈论他对摄影的兴趣。露丝感到厌烦，将注意力转向附近的商店橱窗，希望那男人能领会意图并放过她。当很明显他没领会意思时，露丝终于说她在等丈夫。那男人接着问：
hair that was beginning to grey. He seemed innocuous, dressed in jeans, a plaid shirt and white tennis shoes. The man tried to engage Ruth in small talk, but she wasn't interested and barely acknowledged him. Undeterred, he kept pace, his questions growing more pointed. You work for the telephone company, don't you?" Despite Ruth's clear disinterest, he pressed on. What do you do there? Are you an operator? Ruth remained silent as the man rambled on about his love of gambling in Las Vegas, even inviting her to join him for a trip there sometime. He then began talking about his interest in photography. Annoyed, Ruth turned her attention to the nearby shop windows, hoping the man would take the hint and leave her alone. When it became clear that he wasn't getting the message, Ruth finally said she was waiting for her husband. The man then asked,
“你还结婚吗？”受够了的露丝一言不发。那男人友好的态度突然改变了。他凑近身子，威胁地说道：“我喜欢你的脸。我会再见到你的。你可以指望这一点。有些人的幻想是别人的噩梦。”说完，他气势汹汹地走开了。不久之后，露丝见到了埃德，并告诉了他这次令人不安的遭遇。尽管妻子感到不安，但埃德认为那男人只是在和她调情，对她的拒绝反应过度。私下里，露丝无法摆脱一种挥之不去的怀疑，即他可能就是那个一直试图勒索她的人。但随着几个月过去，那些令人不安的电话停止了，那个城市里的男人也没有再出现。
are you still married? Fed up, Ruth said nothing. The man's friendly demeanor abruptly changed. He leaned in close and said menacingly, I like your face. I'll see you again. You can count on that. Some people's fantasies are other people's nightmares." With that, he stormed off. Ruth met up with Ed shortly afterward and told him about the unsettling encounter. Despite his wife's unease, Ed assumed the man had been flirting with her and had reacted poorly to her rejection. Privately, Ruth couldn't shake the nagging suspicion that he might have been the same man who'd been trying to blackmail her. But as the months passed, the troubling calls stopped and the man in the city didn't reappear.
近一年后，1978年7月，露丝在午休时间走在威奇托的街头，一只手突然从巷子里伸出来，紧紧抓住了她的手腕。她转过身，发现正是11个月前骚扰她的那个男人。惊恐之下，她挣脱开来，冲过马路，那男人大喊：“露丝，给我回来，你这个愚蠢的婊子，跟我说话。”露丝冲进附近的一家百货商店，跑进电梯，疯狂地按下了五楼的按钮。当电梯门重新打开时，她匆忙跑出来，躲在商店的陈列品中，希望那男人找不到她。随着时间流逝，露丝的神经开始平复。最终，她离开了商店，走向一部公用电话。
Nearly a year later, in July 1978, Ruth was walking the streets of Wichita during her lunch break when a hand suddenly shot out from an alleyway and gripped her wrist tightly. She turned to find the man who had accosted her eleven months earlier. Frightened, she broke free and sprinted across the street as the man yelled, Ruth, get back here you stupid bitch and talk to me. Ruth darted into a nearby department store, rushed into an elevator, and frantically pressed the button for the fifth floor. When the doors reopened, she hurried out and concealed herself among the shop displays, hoping the man wouldn't find her. As time passed, Ruth's nerves began to settle. Eventually, she left the store and made her way to a payphone.
她给丈夫打了电话，让他立刻来接她。当埃德赶到时，露丝终于崩溃了，告诉了他过去一年里她所忍受的一切骚扰。埃德得知妻子一直默默承受着这些，感到震惊和难过。他开车送她去警察局报案，但芬利夫妇交谈的那位警官从未跟进，这让夫妇俩不确定他们的案件是被调查了还是被搁置了。几个月后，露丝在家中收到了邮件。一个用黑色大写字母写着她名字的信封引起了她的注意。里面是一张单行纸。上面有着和她前一年收到的那个装有关于她1946年遇袭文章的信封上一样的孩子气笔迹。
She called her husband, telling him to come and get her right away. When Ed arrived, Ruth finally broke down and told him everything about the harassment she'd endured over the past year. Ed was shocked and upset to learn what his wife had been dealing with in silence. was shocked and upset to learn what his wife had been dealing with in silence. He drove her to the police station to file a report, but the officer the Finley spoke to never followed up with them, leaving the couple uncertain as to whether their case had been investigated or brushed aside. Months later, Ruth was at home when the mail arrived. An envelope addressed to her in large black block letters caught her attention. Inside was a single sheet of lined paper. It featured the same childlike handwriting that had been on the envelope she received the previous year that had contained the newspaper article about her 1946
纸的顶部潦草地写着一行字：“去你的，去你的警察，去你的电话公司。”信中其余的内容是一团乱麻，充满了拼写、语法和标点错误。然而，散布在其中的几个复杂的词显得格格不入。本质上，写信人向露丝索要钱财，并威胁如果她不从就伤害她。露丝把信给丈夫看了，他们把它带到了威奇托警察局总部。露丝确信自己与骚扰者没有任何联系。她人缘很好，没有已知的敌人，想不出有谁会如此恶意地针对她。芬利夫妇被介绍给了重案组经验丰富的侦探。
attack. Scrawled at the top of the page was the line, fuck you, fuck the police, fuck the telephone company. The rest of the letter's contents were a rambling mess, filled with poor spelling, grammar and punctuation. Yet, scattered throughout were several complex words that seemed oddly out of place. In essence, the writer demanded money from Ruth and threatened to hurt her if she didn't comply. Ruth showed the letter to her husband and they took it to the Wichita Police Department headquarters. Ruth was certain that she had no connection to her harasser. She was well liked with no known enemies and couldn't think of a single person who would target her so maliciously. The Finleys were introduced to the seasoned detectives of the Major Crimes Division.
露丝和埃德很惊讶他们的案件竟然被升级到了这样一个精英部门。他们很快就会知道令人不安的原因。威奇托在过去三年里一直笼罩在从未有过的恐惧之中。该市第一位已知的连环杀手夺走了七名受害者的生命，其中包括同一家庭的四名成员。杀手给自己起了个绰号叫“BTK勒杀手”，即“捆绑、折磨、杀害”的缩写，反映了他残忍的作案手法。他的罪行上了头条，成为当地人茶余饭后的热门话题，他们生活在持续的恐惧、不确定和怀疑之中。到1978年底，警方对BTK勒杀手是谁没有任何实质性线索，
Ruth and Ed were surprised that their case had been escalated to such an elite unit. They would soon learn the troubling reason why. Wichita had spent the last three years gripped by fear it had never felt before. The city's first known serial killer had claimed the lives of seven victims, including four members of the same family. The killer had adopted the moniker BTK Strangler, which was short for Bind, Torture, Kill, a reflection of his sadistic method of attack. His crimes made headlines and were a hot topic among locals who lived in a state of perpetual terror, uncertainty and suspicion. By late 1978, police had no substantial leads on who the BTK
只有模糊的目击者描述和一系列他寄给当局和媒体的带有挑衅性的图文信件。在信中，BTK勒杀手详细描述了他的罪行，有时还附上令人不安的神秘诗歌。大多数信件都是用独特的块状笔迹手写的。当威奇托重案组得知露丝·芬利的案件时，他们注意到了与BTK作案手法令人不安的相似之处，但差异足以阻止做出明确的联系。由于露丝似乎没有直接的生命危险，她的案件被排在了部门在更大调查中正在梳理的线索堆的底部。
strangler was, only vague witness descriptions and a series of graphic taunting letters that he'd sent to authorities and media outlets. In them, the BTK Strangler detailed his crimes and sometimes included disturbing cryptic poems. Most were handwritten in distinct blocky handwriting. Most were handwritten in distinct blocky handwriting. When Wichita's Major Crimes Division learned of Ruth Finley's case, they noted troubling similarities to BTK's MO, but there were enough differences to prevent an unequivocal connection. Since Ruth didn't appear to be in immediate life-threatening danger, her case was relegated to the bottom of the pile of leads the division was sorting through in the larger investigation.
一周后，露丝又收到了一封信。这封冗长的信中充满了与前一封类似的写作错误，要求露丝在埃德皮卡车的一个座位下留下100美元，并把车停在可以取走现金的地方。作者明确表示，他们知道露丝寻求了丈夫、西南贝尔公司同事甚至警察的帮助，并警告说：“我能看出是否有人在监视我。别再当个蠢婊子把事情搞砸了。如果你这么做，我很快就会见到你。”信的结尾是一首诗。“无论你去哪里，在水上还是陆地，你都得付钱，否则我就说出你的烙印。”
A week later, Ruth received another letter. Filled with similar writing errors to the previous one, this long-winded note demanded that Ruth leave $100 under a seat in Ed's pickup truck and park it in a location where the cash could be collected. The author made it clear that they knew Ruth had enlisted the help of her husband, her colleagues at Southwestern Bell, and even the police, warning, I can tell if anybody is watching me. Don't be a dumb bitch again and blow this. I will have to see you soon if you do." The letter ended with a poem. Wherever you go, on water or land, you still got to pay or I'll tell about your brand.
“说出你的烙印。我很聪明，知道该做什么。你和那些我鄙视的人交谈，比如警察中尉和电话间谍。”露丝把信交给了警察，很快又收到了更多信件，每一封都比上一封更古怪、难以辨认且充满亵渎。信件的笔迹包含几乎无法理解的缩写，有时是倒着写、反着写，或者在页面角落乱涂乱画成圆圈。警方很难理解这些内容。露丝主动把每封信的内容打出来，试图澄清和解码它们。虽然写得很差，但信中包含了像“prolegomenos”（序言）、“constantaneous”（即时的）和“jacktotation”（胡言乱语）这样复杂的词汇，暗示作者比他表现出来的更聪明。露丝不得不查字典来理解这些词的意思。
tell about your brand. I am smart and know things to do. You talk to people I despise, like police lieutenant and telespies." Ruth took the letter to the police, and soon more arrived, each more erratic, illegible and profane than the last. The writing featured near incomprehensible abbreviations and was sometimes penned upside down, backwards, or scribbled in circles at the corners of the page. The police struggled to make sense of them. Ruth took it upon herself to type out the content of each letter in an effort to clarify and decode them. Though poorly written, the letters contained sophisticated words like prolegomenos, constantaneous, and jacktotation, suggesting that the author was more intelligent than they were letting on. Ruth had to look up these words in the dictionary to understand their meaning.
她还发现信中一些精心设计的术语，如“Sanchus”和“psychosthenia”（精神衰弱），完全是编造的。作者仍然对露丝的过去着迷，并经常提到想看她的烙印，这是指她在十几岁时受到的烧伤。她把自己的研究交给了警察，他们很感激她的帮助，但仍然没有紧急处理这种情况。与此同时，令人不安的电话又开始了。如果露丝接听，那男人只是说“露丝”，然后挂断。如果埃德接听，打电话的人会立即挂断。有一天，埃德决定留在电话线上，看看会发生什么。几分钟的沉默后，埃德被电话线里传来的哨声惊到了。
Ruth had to look up these words in the dictionary to understand their meaning. She also discovered that some of the letter's elaborate terms like Sanchus and psychosthenia were entirely made up. The author remained fascinated by Ruth's past and frequently mentioned wanting to see her brands, a reference to the burns she had sustained in her teens. She passed her research on to the police, who were grateful for her help, but still didn't treat the situation with urgency. At the same time, the troubling phone calls resumed. If Ruth answered, the man simply said, Ruth, before hanging up. If Ed answered, the caller immediately hung up. One day, Ed decided to stay on the line and wait to see what happened. Several minutes of silence passed before Ed was startled by a whistling sound blowing down the line.
“是谁？”他质问道。一个陌生的声音终于开口了。“这真是该死的事。我刚才路过市中心邮局的这个电话，它就挂在钩子上。你是谁？”这是一次失败的尝试。无论谁打了那个电话，都已经逃离了现场。到1978年10月，电话停止了。芬利夫妇松了一口气，认为那个人终于放弃并离开了，标志着他们16个月磨难的结束。案件档案很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。送上一份完美的礼物，一份Aura相框，它会不断带来惊喜。这是朋友和家人一定会喜欢的礼物，并被Wirecutter评为最佳数码相框。
down the line. Who is this? he demanded. An unfamiliar voice finally spoke up. This is the damnedest thing. I was walking by this phone here at the post office downtown and it's just hanging off the hook. Who are you? It was a bust. Whoever had made the call had fled the area. was a bust. Whoever had made the call had fled the area. By October 1978, the call stopped. The Finleys were relieved, thinking the man had finally given up and moved on, marking the end of their 16-month ordeal. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Give the perfect gift that keeps on giving, an Aura frame. It's one that friends and family are sure to love and has been named the best digital photo frame by Wirecutter.
Aura相框配有生动的高清显示屏、无限存储空间，并能预装照片和视频。现在，使用促销代码A-CAST，购买Aura最畅销的Carver哑光相框可立减25美元。只需访问AuraFrames.com。即A-U-R-A-Frames.com，促销代码A-CAST。适用相关条款。乔丹·B·彼得森博士，一个改变你人生的夜晚。如果你只说真话，不掺杂其他，你的人生将因此开启一场宏大的冒险。你无法预知会发生什么，但真相会以其本来的面目揭示这个世界。
Aura frames come with a vivid HD display, unlimited storage, and the ability to preload the frame with photos and videos. Right now you can get $25 off Aura's best-selling Carver matte frames by using promo code A-CAST. Just visit AuraFrames.com. That's A-U-R-A-Frames.com promo code A-CAST. Conditions apply. Dr. Jordan B. Peterson, an evening to transform your life. If you say the truth and nothing else, you'll have an immense adventure as a consequence. You won't know what's going to happen to you, but the truth will reveal the world the way it's intended to be revealed.
而你将收获一场终生难忘的冒险。3月6日，斯科舍银行球馆现场直播。立即前往LiveNation.com购票。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。1978年11月21日星期二下午，威奇托天气寒冷潮湿，露丝·芬利下班午休去办些琐事。在为朋友挑选了一张
And the consequence for you will be that you'll have the adventure of your life. Live at Scotiabank Arena March 6th. Get tickets now at LiveNation.com. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. It was cold and wet in Wichita on the afternoon of Tuesday November 21, 1978 when Ruth Finlay stepped out on her lunch break to run a few errands. After picking up a
生日贺卡后，她穿过北市场街，突然产生了一种被人跟踪的令人不安的感觉。她转过身，但那里空无一人。露丝继续前行，突然，一辆蓝绿色的旧款1964年雪佛兰Bel Air停在路边，挡住了她的去路。一个男人从车里跳出来，质问道：“你拿到我的钱了吗？”正是露丝之前遇到过两次的那个男人，这次他穿着牛仔夹克，里面套着毛衣，戴着黑框眼镜。他要求露丝上他的车，但她吓呆了，无法动弹或说话。那男人用力踢了露丝的胫骨，痛得她弯下了腰。随后他强行把她塞进Bel Air的后座，
birthday card for a friend, she crossed North Market Street and was struck by an unnerving feeling that she was being followed. She turned around, but no one was there. Ruth continued on her way when, all of a sudden, an old blue-green 1964 Chevrolet Bel Air pulled up to the curb, blocking her path. A man jumped out of the vehicle and demanded, have you got my money? It was the man Ruth had encountered twice before, this time wearing a denim jacket over a sweater and black framed glasses. He demanded that Ruth get into his car, but she froze in fear, unable to move or speak. The man kicked Ruth hard in the shin, causing her to double over in pain. He then forced her into the back seat of the Bel Air and
爬到她身边坐下。另一个人坐在驾驶座上。他猛踩油门，车子向前冲去。这辆车已经破旧不堪。破烂的后座上堆满了露丝认为是从农场弄来的垃圾——汽油罐、混凝土块、铁链和抹布。左后窗用塑料胶带粘着，乘客门被撞瘪了，仪表盘用白胶带修补过。车子行驶时，两个男人不停地交谈，轮流喝着一瓶用棕色纸包裹的酒。露丝努力捕捉他们谈话的内容。她推断司机叫巴迪，但没听清抓住她的那个男人的名字。那男人很快把注意力转回露丝身上，要求
climbed in beside her. A second man sat behind the wheel. He hit the accelerator and the car shot forward. The car had seen better days. The tattered backseat was cluttered with the junk that Ruth assumed had come from a farm – gas cans, chunks of concrete, chains, and rags. farm. Gas cans, chunks of concrete, chains, and rags. The left rear window was taped with plastic, the passenger door was bashed in, and the dashboard was patched with white tape. As they drove along, the two men talked incessantly, taking long swigs from a bottle wrapped in brown paper that they passed between them. Ruth strained to catch as much of their conversation as she could. She deduced that the driver was called Buddy, but she didn't catch the name of the man who'd grabbed her. The man soon turned his attention back to Ruth and demanded
她交出钱包。露丝交出了钱包，那男人翻找了一番，然后兴高采烈地宣布：“我们发财了。”但当他发现一张处理她案件的侦探的名片时，他的心情变坏了。他把名片给巴迪看，两人交换了一连串愤怒的脏话。毫无预兆地，那男人用一块混凝土块击中了露丝的脸侧，咆哮道：“你这个该死的蠢婊子。”露丝坐在后面，神志不清，沉默不语，而巴迪在城里漫无目的地开车。她偶尔瞥见那个抓住她的男人挥舞着一把弹簧刀。
she give him her purse. Ruth handed it over and the man rummaged through it before announcing gleefully, we've struck it rich. But his mood soured when he found a business card for one of the detectives working on her case. He showed it to Buddy and the two men exchanged a volley of angry profanities. Without warning, the man struck Ruth in the side of the face with a chunk of concrete, barking, you damn stupid bitch. Ruth sat back, dazed and silent, while Buddy drove aimlessly through the city. She occasionally caught glimpses of her cap door wielding a switchblade. She occasionally caught glimpses of her cap door wielding a switchblade.
逃跑的念头闪过她的脑海，但她旁边的门把手坏了，她不确定如果从飞驰的车上跳下去能否活命。她的钱包被还了回来，里面有一罐防狼喷雾，但她想不出如何在不被那男人发现的情况下取出来。有一次，露丝无意中听到巴迪不祥地说：“等到天黑。”当他把车开进双湖购物中心的停车场时，她的焦虑感加剧了。另一个人嘟囔道：“我们会除掉她，但不是在这里。”
Thoughts of escape crossed her mind, but the door handle next to her was broken, and she wasn't sure she'd survive if she jumped from the speeding car. Her purse had been returned, and inside it was a can of mace, but she couldn't figure out how to retrieve it without the man noticing. At one point, Ruth overheard Buddy ominously say, wait until dark. Her anxiety spiked when he pulled into the parking lot of the Twin Lakes shopping centre. The other man muttered, we'll get rid of her, but not here. The other man muttered, We'll get rid of her, but not here.
与此同时，在西南贝尔公司，露丝的同事们注意到她午休没回来。他们给埃德·芬利打了电话，然后又报了警，但由于没人知道露丝的确切位置，她的处境变得危急。几个小时过去了，太阳落山了，露丝的绑架者继续开车带着她在城里转悠。在此期间，露丝对自己的遭遇感到绝望。有一次，后座的男人冷笑道：“你喜欢啤酒吗？我们去买点啤酒开个派对。我会对你很好的。”在磨难的第四个小时，露丝终于鼓起勇气开口，告诉那男人她需要上厕所。他们嘲笑她，于是露丝强迫自己干呕，解释说如果不到厕所她就会吐出来。虽然他们似乎很怀疑，但巴迪还是把车停在西21街和萨利纳附近的一个小公园，靠近小阿肯色河。为了防止露丝逃跑，
Meanwhile, back at South Western Belle, Ruth's colleagues noticed that she hadn't returned from lunch. Calls were made to Ed Finley and then to the police, but without anyone knowing Ruth's exact location, her situation grew dire. Hours passed and the sun set as Ruth's captors continued driving her around town. All the while, Ruth despaired over what might be in store for her. At one point, the man in the back seat sneered, Do you like beer? We'll get some beer and have a party. I'll be real nice to you. By the fourth hour of her ordeal, Ruth finally found the courage to speak up, telling the man that she needed to use the restroom. They laughed at her, so Ruth forced herself to gag, explaining that she would throw up if she didn't get to a toilet. Although they seemed dubious, Buddy pulled up at a small park near West 21st Street and Salina, close to the little Arkansas River. To prevent Ruth from fleeing,
男人们命令她交出外套和鞋子。露丝的绑架者下了车，拽着她的胳膊走进公园，评论道：“我会看着你，你也会看着我。这听起来不是很开心吗？”走着走着，露丝悄悄把手伸进钱包，紧紧握住防狼喷雾罐。当他们到达一个小湖边时，那男人松开了对露丝的控制，以便先小便。当他拉开裤子拉链时，露丝抓起喷雾剂喷向他。那男人咳嗽着瘫倒在地，给了露丝逃跑的机会。她赤着脚，冲过泥泞的地面，滑下一个堤岸，蹲在一丛大灌木后面。她听到那男人大喊：“‘如果我们把你留在这里，你会冻死的。过来拿你的鞋子和外套，
the men ordered that she hand over her coat and shoes. Ruth's captor got out of the car and dragged her by the arm into the park, remarking, I'll watch you and you'll watch me. Doesn't that sound like fun? As they walked, Ruth discreetly tucked her hand into her purse, gripping the can of mace. When they reached a small lake, the man released his hold on Ruth so that he could urinate first. As he unzipped his pants, Ruth grabbed the mace and sprayed it at him. The man collapsed in a coughing fit, giving Ruth the opportunity to flee. Barefoot, she darted across the muddy ground, slid down an embankment, and crouched behind a large bush. She heard the man yell, "'You'll freeze if we leave you here. Come and get your shoes and your coat,
我们就不会再打扰你了。’”露丝保持沉默，身体颤抖，双脚因寒冷而麻木。她躲在黑暗中，直到那男人停止叫喊，她感觉到他已经离开了。露丝从灌木丛后爬出来，爬回小土坡，扫描着Bel Air的踪迹。它不见了。她迅速离开公园，跑到路对面的一家酒类商店，大喊：“有人在追我。”店员立即报了警，警察赶到接走了露丝，并将她带到警察局，在那里她与丈夫埃德团聚了。露丝得知绑架者偷走了她315美元的工资支票、一张100美元的美国储蓄债券以及其他一些随机物品，包括一些文具。警方检查了露丝被带去的公园。他们在堤岸附近发现了她的鞋子和外套，
and we won't bother you anymore.'" Ruth remained silent, her body shivering and her feet numb from the cold. She stayed hidden in the dark until the man stopped shouting and she sensed he had gone. Ruth crept out from behind the bush and climbed back up the small rise, scanning the area for the Bel Air. It was nowhere to be seen. She quickly left the park and ran to a liquor store across the road, yelling, someone's after me. The store clerk immediately called the police, who arrived to collect Ruth and take her to the station, where she was reunited with her husband dad. Ruth learned that her abductors had stolen her $315 paycheck, a $100 US savings bond, and a few other random items, including some stationery. Police examined the park where Ruth had been taken. They found her shoes and coat near the embankment
她就是从那里逃走的，还有显示她逃跑路线的脚印。然而，袭击者没有留下其他线索。警方对每一款符合露丝描述的雪佛兰车型进行了局部检查，每辆车都被追踪并排除了嫌疑。侦探们还重新审视了1946年露丝遇袭的案件，前往斯科特堡寻找线索。与此同时，露丝继续收到折磨者寄来的冗长杂乱的信件。在其中一封信里，他附上了从她钱包里偷走的文具，证实了写信人和绑架者是同一个人。在另一封信中，他指责露丝故意迷惑他。他声称自己把露丝的
she had fled down, along with footprints showing her escape route. However, the assailants had left behind no other clues. A localised check on every model of Chevrolet that matched Ruth's description was conducted, with each vehicle tracked down and ruled out. description was conducted, with each vehicle tracked down and ruled out. Detectives also revisited the 1946 attack on Ruth, travelling to Fort Scott to search for leads. In the meantime, Ruth continued to receive long rambling letters from her tormentor. In one, he enclosed the stationery that was stolen from her purse, confirming that the letter-writer and the abductor were one and the same. In another letter, he accused Ruth of deliberately confusing him. He claimed to have mistaken Ruth's
妹妹简误认成了她，这是一个常见的错误，因为姐妹俩长得很像。简得知那个男人也一直在误认并跟踪她时，感到非常不安。露丝试图安慰她，说：“他不要你。他要的是我。”露丝陷入了绝望。她的头痛现在每天都会发生，并伴有严重的腹痛。当那男人开始在威奇托各地留下关于露丝的信件并写信给当地报纸时，情况变得更糟了。这把露丝推向了聚光灯下，使这位原本私密且内向的女性成了当地流言蜚语的对象。那男人声称自己是个诗人，尽管人们并不知道。这一点，加上他习惯
sister, Jean, for her, a common mistake as the two sisters looked alike. Jean was rattled when she learned that the man had been mistakenly stalking her as well. Ruth tried to reassure her, saying, He doesn't want you. He wants me. Ruth was in a state of despair. Her headaches were now a daily occurrence and accompanied by crippling abdominal pain. Things worsened when the man began leaving letters about Ruth throughout Wichita and writing to the local papers. This thrust Ruth into the spotlight and made the otherwise private and reserved woman the subject of local gossip. The man claimed he was a poet, though people didn't know it. This, along with his habit
创作暴力和色情的韵文，导致他被称为“诗人”。有时他的诗很长且复杂，有时又短而简单，类似于儿歌。在信中，他称露丝为妓女，这种指控似乎完全没有根据。侦探们与露丝进行了长时间的交谈，得出结论：她是一位善良、正直、经常去教堂的女性，对丈夫非常忠诚。这不是一个过着秘密双重生活的已婚妇女的案件。他们能看出露丝的恐惧是真实的，她确实不知道“诗人”是谁，也不知道为什么自己会被针对。尽管如此，“诗人”继续暗示他们之间存在个人联系，写道：“你知道在你那扭曲的脑子里，你终将死去。你不知道什么时候，但你知道为什么。”
for penning violent and sexual rhymes, led to him being referred to as the poet. Sometimes his poems were long and elaborate, other times they were short and simple, resembling children's rhymes. In his writings he called Ruth a whore, an accusation that seemed completely unfounded. Detectives spoke at length with Ruth and concluded that she was a kind, upstanding, church-going woman who was fiercely devoted to her husband. This wasn't a case of a married woman living a secret double life. They could tell Ruth's fear was genuine and that she truly had no idea who the poet was or why she was being targeted. Despite this, the poet continued to imply a personal connection between them, writing, You know in your fucked up mind you are going to die. You don't know when, but you do know why.
在给当地报纸《鹰灯塔报》的一封信中，诗人对自己的匿名性沾沾自喜。“善或恶，我的秘密不会被知晓。我悄无声息地走我的路。我或许能繁荣一天。”他还斥责该出版物在同一篇文章中同时提到他和BTK勒杀手，警告他们不要再混淆这些行刑者。他声称：“我并不危险，只是对那些太蠢而不听话的人来说。”他甚至给负责露丝案件的一名侦探寄了一封信，指责他保护了我们的“妓女”免于死亡。为了产生更多线索，侦探参加了一个现场广播脱口秀节目，详细描述了露丝的遭遇。在广播期间，露丝仔细聆听了每一个打进电台的电话，
In a letter to local newspaper The Eagle Beacon, the poet gloated about his anonymity. newspaper The Eagle Beacon, the poet gloated about his anonymity. Good or evil, my secret shall not be known. I unnoticed go my way. I may just prosper for one day. He also scolded the publication for mentioning both him and the BTK Strangler in the same article, warning them not to confuse the executioners again. I am not dangerous, he claimed, just to those who are too dumb to do what they are told. He even sent a letter to a detective overseeing Ruth's case, accusing him of protecting our quote, whore from death. In an effort to generate more leads, the detective appeared on a live radio talk show and described Ruth's ordeal in detail. During the broadcast, Ruth listened closely to each incoming call to the radio station,
但没有一个打电话的人听起来像她的跟踪者。每天晚上，当露丝睡觉时，埃德都会守在房子外面，躲在灌木丛中，手持一把12号口径猎枪和一把左轮手枪。芬利夫妇在1979年断断续续地继续收到信件，有时一次收到两封。他们试图在生活中保持一种正常感，甚至为他们一年一度的科罗拉多州西部牧场度假做准备。8月13日星期一，当露丝正在打包行李时，她意识到自己需要一条新牛仔裤。放下恐惧，她开车去了东城购物中心，买了她需要的东西。当她购物结束时，天色已晚，太阳正在落山。当她走回车里时，露丝产生了一种令人不安的感觉，好像有人在跟踪她。然而，每次她转过身，停车场似乎都空无一人。
but none of the callers sounded like her stalker. Each night, while Ruth slept, Ed kept watch over the house, hiding in the bushes armed with a 12-gauge shotgun and a revolver. The Finleys continued to receive letters sporadically into 1979, sometimes as many as two at a time. They tried to maintain a sense of normalcy in their lives, even preparing for their annual trip to a ranch resort in western Colorado. On Monday, August 13, while Ruth was packing for the trip, she realised she needed a new pair of jeans. Putting her fears aside, she drove to Town East Mall and bought what she needed a new pair of jeans. Putting her fears aside, she drove to Town East Mall and bought what she needed. By the time she finished shopping, it was late and the sun was setting. As she walked back to her car, Ruth was struck by the unsettling sensation that someone was following her. However, each time she turned around, the parking lot seemed deserted,
但没有一个来电者的声音听起来像她的跟踪者。每天晚上，当露丝睡觉时，埃德都会守在房子外面，躲在灌木丛中，手里拿着一把12口径的霰弹枪和一把左轮手枪。芬利一家在1979年期间仍零星地收到信件，有时一次多达两封。他们试图保持生活的正常感，甚至为他们每年去科罗拉多州西部一个牧场度假村的旅行做准备。8月13日星期一，当露丝正在为旅行打包行李时，她意识到自己需要一条新牛仔裤。她放下恐惧，开车去了东城购物中心，买了她需要的东西。当她购物结束时，天色已晚，太阳正在落山。当她走回车里时，露丝产生了一种不安的感觉，觉得有人在跟踪她。然而，每当她回头看时，停车场似乎空无一人。
with no one in sight. Nervous, Ruth hurried toward her car when a familiar voice called out. Hey Ruth, I didn't know you were going to make this so easy. Ruth broke into a sprint. She reached her car and jammed a key into the door, but it wouldn't open. She had used the wrong key. A gloved hand appeared from behind her and grabbed her wrist. It was the same man who had abducted her the year before. He pushed Ruth's head against the car and ordered her to get in, tossing a brown paper shopping bag through the partially open rear window. We'll go to a nice little place where it says, keep out, he said. Ruth pushed the man away and tried to run, but within seconds he pulled an 8-inch boning knife from his
周围空无一人。露丝紧张地快步走向她的车，这时一个熟悉的声音叫住了她。嘿，露丝，我没想到你会让事情变得这么简单。露丝开始飞奔。她跑到车前，把钥匙插进车门，但门打不开。她用错钥匙了。一只戴着手套的手从她身后伸出来，抓住了她的手腕。正是去年绑架她的那个男人。他把露丝的头按在车上，命令她上车，并把一个棕色的纸质购物袋从半开的后窗扔了进去。他说，我们要去一个写着“禁止入内”的好地方。露丝推开那个男人试图逃跑，但几秒钟内，他就从口袋里掏出一把8英寸长的剔骨刀，
pocket and stabbed her twice in the back and once in the side. Fuelled by adrenaline and desperation, Ruth scrambled into her car. The man reached through the open driver's side window, but she managed to wind it up quickly, trapping his hand for a moment before he withdrew. Ruth started the engine and sped off, the boning knife still lodged in her side. Blood soaked into the car seat as she fought back tears, her body wracked with pain. She pulled into a gas station and called the police from a payphone. They urged her to stay put, but terrified that the man might be following her, Ruth got back into her car and drove home. By the time she arrived, her vision blurred and she was on the verge of passing out.
并在她的背上刺了两刀，侧面刺了一刀。在肾上腺素和绝望的驱使下，露丝挣扎着爬进车里。那个男人从打开的驾驶座车窗伸手进来，但她设法迅速摇上车窗，夹住了他的手片刻，直到他缩回手。露丝发动引擎疾驰而去，剔骨刀还插在她的侧身。鲜血浸透了座椅，她强忍着泪水，身体因剧痛而颤抖。她把车开进一个加油站，用公用电话报了警。警察催促她留在原地，但露丝担心那个男人可能在跟踪她，于是又回到车里开车回家。当她到达时，视线已经模糊，几乎要昏厥过去。
Ed rushed to Ruth the moment she pulled up. He gently moved her into the passenger seat and drove to the hospital, while Ruth drifted in and out of consciousness. The doctors concluded that Ruth had been incredibly lucky. If the knife had been a fraction of an inch deeper, her kidney would have been punctured and she would have died. The paper bag her attacker threw into her back seat painted a harrowing image of his intentions. It contained clothesline rope, white tape, a red bandana, and a half-empty bottle of wine. After a successful surgery and nine days of recovery under 24-hour police protection, Ruth was cleared to return home. Before she arrived, the police thoroughly examined every inch of the Finley's house and deemed it safe. Not long after Ruth was released from hospital, a detective arrived at the Finley's door,
埃德在她停车的瞬间冲向露丝。他轻轻地把她移到副驾驶座上，开车送她去医院，而露丝则处于半昏迷状态。医生断定露丝非常幸运。如果刀再深几分之一英寸，她的肾脏就会被刺穿，她也就没命了。袭击者扔进她后座的纸袋描绘了一幅令人毛骨悚然的意图画面。里面装有晾衣绳、白胶带、一条红头巾和半瓶酒。经过成功的手术和在24小时警察保护下九天的恢复，露丝获准回家。在她到达之前，警方彻底检查了芬利家房子的每一个角落，认为它是安全的。露丝出院后不久，一名侦探来到芬利家门口，
visibly shaken. He explained that he'd received a call from the hospital where Ruth had been treated. A man had shown up, asking specifically for her. A nurse believed he might have been Ruth's assailant, but by the time authorities arrived, he'd already left. Fearing for her safety, police quietly moved Ruth to a safe location. In the days that followed, they kept the Finley's house under constant surveillance, but the man didn't appear. News of Ruth's stabbing made headlines across Wichita, with composite sketches of the offender
神情明显不安。他解释说，他接到了露丝接受治疗的医院打来的电话。一个男人出现在医院，专门打听她。一名护士认为他可能是露丝的袭击者，但当当局赶到时，他已经离开了。出于对她安全的担忧，警方悄悄将露丝转移到了一个安全地点。在接下来的几天里，他们对芬利家进行了持续监视，但那个男人没有出现。露丝被刺的消息登上了威奇托各地的头条新闻，罪犯的模拟画像
widely circulated and a $3,000 reward offered for information leading to his capture. At one point, the Poet case generated more tips than the higher-profile BTK Strangler investigation. Detectives began looking into individuals with criminal backgrounds that matched the poet's behaviour. They showed Ruth photos of potential suspects, but she ruled each of them out. At one stage, the investigation turned toward the Finleys themselves. Ed was questioned thoroughly, but he assured the police that he would never hurt his wife. The FBI compared his handwriting with that of the poet and determined it wasn't a match.
被广泛散发，并悬赏3000美元征集抓捕他的线索。一度，“诗人”案产生的线索比备受瞩目的BTK连环杀手调查还要多。侦探们开始调查那些犯罪背景与“诗人”行为相符的人。他们给露丝看了潜在嫌疑人的照片，但她一一排除了。在某个阶段，调查转向了芬利夫妇自己。埃德受到了彻底的盘问，但他向警方保证，他绝不会伤害自己的妻子。联邦调查局将他的笔迹与“诗人”的笔迹进行了比对，确定并不匹配。
Additionally, a medical report ruled out the possibility that Ruth could have inflicted the stab wounds to herself at such an angle and with such force. An independent doctor reached the same conclusion. For a while, Ruth was closely monitored by eight plainclothes police officers as she went about her daily activities outside the home. On some occasions, a detective hid out of sight in the back of her car armed with a shotgun. Others patrolled the city in unmarked police cars or went undercover, spending weeks lurking through Wichita, keeping an eye out for the poet. But he managed to elude them. In an attempt to lure him out, Ed Finley posted a coded message in the classified section of
此外，一份医疗报告排除了露丝以这种角度和力度自残的可能性。一位独立医生也得出了同样的结论。有一段时间，露丝在户外进行日常活动时，受到八名便衣警察的密切监视。有时，一名侦探会带着猎枪躲在她的车后座。其他人则开着无标志的警车在城里巡逻，或者进行卧底，在威奇托潜伏数周，留意“诗人”的踪迹。但他设法躲过了他们。为了引诱他出来，埃德·芬利在《鹰信报》的分类广告栏里发布了一条加密信息。
the Eagle Beacon. The ad read, Poet, tell me what I owe you. It was signed with Ruth's initials, RSF. To Ed's surprise, the poet seemingly responded, To RSF, the price of my service, to stay alive, can now be settled at five. The cryptic nature of the message left Ed and the police baffled. The poet continued to communicate to them through the newspaper, though his messages offered no new or helpful information.
广告上写着：“诗人，告诉我我欠你什么。”落款是露丝的首字母缩写RSF。令埃德惊讶的是，“诗人”似乎回应了：“致RSF，我服务的代价，为了活命，现在可以以五结算。”这条信息的神秘性质让埃德和警方感到困惑。此后，“诗人”继续通过报纸与他们交流，尽管他的信息没有提供任何新的或有用的线索。
As time wore on, Ruth's fear gave way to profound depression. She felt utterly helpless, resigned to the belief that the poet would eventually get her. The sense of dread grew when the Finleys found another letter from the poet wedged in the slats of their front porch, marking the first time he'd personally delivered a letter to their home. At night, they began hearing strange noises coming from their garage, leading them to believe someone was lurking there. Then, on Christmas Eve of 1979, their phone lines were cut. Ruth agreed to undergo hypnosis in an attempt to uncover any suppressed memories of her abduction and stabbing. In the first session, she quickly slipped into a trance and recounted the events in vivid detail, even shouting, I want out of the car, as she relived the abduction.
随着时间的推移，露丝的恐惧让位于深深的抑郁。她感到彻底无助，屈服于“诗人”最终会抓住她的信念。当芬利夫妇发现另一封“诗人”的信塞在他们前廊的板条里时，这种恐惧感加剧了，这是他第一次亲自把信送到他们家。晚上，他们开始听到车库里传来奇怪的声音，这让他们认为有人潜伏在那里。然后，在1979年的平安夜，他们的电话线被切断了。露丝同意接受催眠，试图挖掘出任何关于她被绑架和刺伤的压抑记忆。在第一次治疗中，她很快进入了恍惚状态，并生动地讲述了事件的细节，甚至在重温绑架过程时大喊：“我要下车！”
However, no new insights emerged from this first session. During her second session a few days later, Ruth recalled that her attacker had mentioned something about a bridge over a river near the airfield east of town. Detectives followed this fresh lead and eventually located a bridge matching Ruth's description, but they couldn't determine its relevance to the case. Later, the poet sent the police written instructions to meet him at the bridge, but he never showed up. In another letter, he referred to a box full of things the police would love to find, allegedly near a rocky stream. Officers spent eight hours digging
然而，这次治疗并没有产生新的见解。几天后的第二次治疗中，露丝回忆起袭击者提到过城东机场附近的一座河上桥梁。侦探们顺着这条新线索，最终找到了符合露丝描述的桥，但他们无法确定它与案件的关联。后来，“诗人”给警方寄去了书面指示，让他们在桥上见面，但他从未露面。在另一封信中，他提到了一个装满警察很想找到的东西的盒子，据称就在一条多石的小溪附近。警官们花了八个小时挖掘
along a dry riverbed near the airfield, but found nothing. Riverbed near the airfield, but found nothing. The psychologist who had hypnotised Ruth suggested that the poet might have received psychological treatment or spent time in a state institution. He described the attacker as withdrawn, seclusive, secretive and suspicious. After reviewing the poet's letters, the psychologist confirmed that the author was highly intelligent. A prominent psycholinguist created a psychological profile of the poet, describing him as severely psychotic, schizophrenic, pathologically paranoid, and a loner with a deep sense of persecution.
机场附近的一条干涸河床，但一无所获。催眠露丝的心理学家建议，“诗人”可能接受过心理治疗或在州立机构待过。他将袭击者描述为孤僻、隐居、神秘且多疑。在审阅了“诗人”的信件后，心理学家证实作者非常聪明。一位杰出的心理语言学家为“诗人”创建了心理侧写，将其描述为严重的精神病患者、精神分裂症患者、病态偏执狂，以及一个有着深刻受迫害感的独行侠。
Although he acknowledged that the poet and the BTK strangler shared a highly similar style and pathology, he didn't believe they were the same person. While the investigation kept stalling, the letters to Ruth continued to arrive. One read, You'll not go directly to your tomb. Your mind must give thought. There will be gloom. Your face no more will anyone meet.
尽管他承认“诗人”和BTK连环杀手有着非常相似的风格和病理特征，但他不认为他们是同一个人。当调查陷入停滞时，寄给露丝的信件却不断到来。其中一封写道：“你不会直接去你的坟墓。你的思想必须思考。会有阴霾。没有人会再见到你的脸。”
At home, day or night, or in the street. Your mind is beaten, dark, forever more hid. All because of what you did. This game is fun to plan and plot, but can you stop me? No, you cannot." The poet remained active into 1980 and a new officer in command was assigned to oversee the case. The poet mocked him in a letter, writing, There once was a captain who had an asshole for a heart. The Finley's house gate was rigged with an alarm and the police hid a surveillance camera in a birdhouse in the backyard. The wires snaked through a garden hose leading to a monitor on the Finley's dining table, producing a live feed. Police officers worked round the clock to monitor the feed 24-7,
“无论是在家里、白天还是晚上，还是在街上。你的思想被击垮了，黑暗，永远隐藏。这一切都是因为你所做的事。这个游戏计划和策划起来很有趣，但你能阻止我吗？不，你不能。”“诗人”在1980年依然活跃，一位新的指挥官被指派负责此案。他在一封信中嘲弄了这位指挥官，写道：“曾经有一位队长，他的心像个混蛋。”芬利家的门被安装了警报器，警方在后院的鸟屋里藏了一个监控摄像头。电线穿过花园软管，连接到芬利家餐桌上的监视器，产生实时画面。警官们全天候24小时监控画面，
but eventually, the poet managed to inconspicuously cut the garden hose. In January, Ruth received a call at work. In January, Ruth received a call at work. "'I have a surprise for you in the lobby,' the poet said, before abruptly hanging up. Ruth immediately contacted the police, who arrived to find a 12-inch butcher knife wrapped in a red bandana in the lobby's phone booth. Two witnesses reported seeing a man matching the poet's description near the booth, but he had left by the time authorities arrived. Two days later, Ruth received another chilling poem. Shut your eyes and think of the twelve-inch blade. Will you remember the hole it made?
但最终，“诗人”还是设法不动声色地切断了花园软管。一月，露丝在工作中接到一个电话。“我在大厅里为你准备了一个惊喜，”那个“诗人”说完，便突然挂断了电话。露丝立即联系了警方，他们赶到后在大厅的电话亭里发现了一把用红头巾包裹的12英寸屠刀。两名目击者报告说看到一个符合“诗人”描述的男人在电话亭附近，但当当局赶到时他已经离开了。两天后，露丝收到了另一首令人不寒而栗的诗。“闭上眼睛，想想那把十二英寸的刀。你会记得它造成的洞吗？”
Dream of me and obey my commands. Think of me with a knife in my hands." In February, the poet sent Ruth a strip of red bandana tied with twine accompanied by a letter that read, "'Here's to you tender Valentine, red with blood and tied with twine. Nothing too much for a valentine, gone from here by whim of mind." By this point, the Finley's entire life was consumed by the poet. Much of their day was spent examining their home for letters, attempting to decode his latest ramblings, speaking with the police, and worrying about his next move. They barely slept, with Ed reaching for his gun at every creek in the night. The poet went to great lengths to upend every facet of Ruth's life. He sent a letter to a
“梦见我并服从我的命令。想想我手里拿着刀的样子。”二月，“诗人”给露丝寄来了一条用麻绳系着的红头巾碎片，并附上一封信，上面写着：“这是给你的，温柔的情人，血红的颜色，用麻绳系着。对于一个情人来说，什么都不算多，随心所欲地离开这里。”此时，芬利夫妇的整个生活都被“诗人”占据了。他们大部分时间都在检查家里是否有信件，试图破译他最新的胡言乱语，与警方交谈，并担心他的下一步行动。他们几乎无法入睡，埃德在夜里听到任何吱吱声都会去拿枪。那个“诗人”费尽心思去颠覆露丝生活的方方面面。他给一家
local florist instructing them to deliver a single black flower to her. He wrote to Ruth's bank, demanding the transfer of all her funds. He contacted the Kansas Department of Motor Vehicles, falsely claiming that Ruth had been driving recklessly and urging them to revoke her driver's licence. Utility providers received letters requesting that the Finley household's gas and electricity be shut off. A locksmith was asked to create a new set of keys for their home, while a construction company was instructed to dump a mound of dirt in their driveway. A towing company was told to collect the Finleys' vehicles, and the health department was falsely informed that Ruth was spreading venereal diseases.
当地花店写信，指示他们送给她一朵黑花。他写信给露丝的银行，要求转走她所有的资金。他联系了堪萨斯州机动车管理局，谎称露丝一直在鲁莽驾驶，并敦促他们吊销她的驾照。公用事业供应商收到了要求切断芬利家天然气和电力的信件。一名锁匠被要求为他们的家制作一套新钥匙，而一家建筑公司则被指示在他们的车道上倾倒一堆泥土。一家拖车公司被告知去收走芬利夫妇的车，卫生部门也被谎报称露丝正在传播性病。
The most chilling correspondence was sent to a local mortuary, warning them that Ruth would soon be in need of their services. Detectives compared the poet's handwriting to samples from a wide range of sources, but no match was found. The letters underwent extensive analysis, focusing on word choice, phrasing, and writing patterns, but these efforts also yielded no results. Chemical testing for fingerprints or saliva on the envelopes came up inconclusive. At one stage, the police received a call from someone claiming to be Buddy, one of the men who had abducted Ruth back in November 1978. The man promised to call back, but never followed through. Numerous hoaxes and mentally ill
最令人不寒而栗的信件被寄往当地的一家殡仪馆，警告他们露丝很快就需要他们的服务了。侦探们将“诗人”的笔迹与来自各种来源的样本进行了比对，但没有发现匹配。这些信件经过了广泛的分析，重点关注用词、措辞和书写模式，但这些努力也没有产生任何结果。对信封上的指纹或唾液进行的化学测试也没有得出结论。在某个阶段，警方接到一个自称是“巴迪”的人打来的电话，此人正是1978年11月绑架露丝的男人之一。那个人承诺会再打来，但从未兑现。无数恶作剧者和精神病
individuals also claimed to be the poet, further complicating the investigation. In early June 1980, the first letter from the poet arrived that wasn't postmarked from Wichita, but from Oklahoma City, 160 miles to the south. Around the same time, police received an anonymous tip saying that a man resembling the poet was living in a trailer west of the city, having been fired from his job seven months earlier. Detectives looked into his psychological profile, which appeared to match the poet's. Hopeful that they finally had a promising lead, they organised for Ruth Finley to view the man in a police line-up. She determined that he was not her stalker.
患者也声称自己是“诗人”，这进一步使调查复杂化。1980年6月初，第一封不是从威奇托邮戳寄出的“诗人”信件到达了，而是来自南边160英里外的俄克拉荷马城。大约在同一时间，警方收到一条匿名举报，称一个长得像“诗人”的男人住在城西的一辆拖车里，七个月前被解雇了。侦探们调查了他的心理侧写，看起来与“诗人”相符。他们满怀希望地认为终于有了有希望的线索，于是安排露丝·芬利在警察列队中辨认该男子。她断定他不是跟踪她的人。
Over a month and a half later, the poet escalated once more, leaving a bottle of urine on the Finley's front porch. This was just one of many disturbing items he had placed on the couple's property during his reign of terror. Among the other objects were an ice pick, firecrackers, cigarettes, hair, matches, and trash. On several occasions, the Finleys discovered ingredients for Molotov cocktails. Eggs were thrown at their house, broken glass was scattered on their front steps,
一个半月后，“诗人”再次升级，在芬利家的前廊留下了一瓶尿液。这只是他在恐怖统治期间放在这对夫妇房产上的众多令人不安的物品之一。其他物品中还有冰镐、鞭炮、香烟、头发、火柴和垃圾。有几次，芬利夫妇发现了制造莫洛托夫鸡尾酒的原料。鸡蛋被扔向他们的房子，碎玻璃散落在前台阶上，
and the lock on their gate was damaged. Ed was horrified when he found a bag containing feces. The situation reached a horrifying peak in December 1980. The Finleys were watching television in their basement one Sunday night when they were startled by the sound of glass smashing. Rushing upstairs, they found that the Christmas wreath on their front door had been set alight, the flames cracking the glass in the door. Ed quickly put out the blaze, then grabbed a pair of garden shears and sprinted down the road, intent on confronting the poet. But he never caught up with him.
大门的锁也被损坏了。当埃德发现一个装有粪便的袋子时，他感到非常震惊。1980年12月，情况达到了令人恐惧的顶峰。一个周日晚上，芬利夫妇正在地下室看电视，突然被玻璃破碎的声音惊醒。他们冲上楼，发现前门上的圣诞花环被点燃了，火焰震碎了门上的玻璃。埃德迅速扑灭了大火，然后抓起一把园艺剪刀冲向马路，打算与“诗人”对质。但他没能追上他。
Afterwards, the poet sent the couple a chilling poem written in the style of the famous Christmas classic, Twas the Night Before Christmas. The verses ominously warned of Ruth's impending death. Twas the night before Christmas and all through the house, Ruth wasn't stirring. You're as quiet as a mouse. Your stocking was tight around your neck with care. I hoped the lieutenant would not soon be there." Fearing an attack, a detective spent Christmas Eve at the Finley's home as they hosted a family get-together. During the night, the Finley's phone lines were cut for a second time, without anyone hearing a thing.
事后，“诗人”给这对夫妇寄来了一首令人不寒而栗的诗，风格模仿了著名的圣诞经典《圣诞前夜》。诗句不祥地警告了露丝即将到来的死亡。“圣诞前夜，屋里静悄悄，露丝没动静。你像老鼠一样安静。你的长筒袜紧紧地勒住你的脖子。我希望中尉不会很快出现在那里。”出于对袭击的恐惧，一名侦探在平安夜待在芬利家，当时他们正在举办家庭聚会。夜里，芬利家的电话线第二次被切断，没有人听到任何动静。
Another holiday-themed poem alluded to Ruth's seedy past of sexual impropriety, saying, "...Once upon the night so dreary, premonitions of disaster keep you weary. The whore bore her guilt in her bed of slime from selling her ass and not charging a dime. Slept with strangers in evil bed, enraged demon hunters saw blood was red. All bitches should keep their names and faces secret. Defenseless instincts released with demonic sluts threats. Blurred vision and suffering in accuser's cage, umbilical cord connected by seed in a rage. In January 1981, the Finley's phone lines were cut for a third time. However, after the poet's previous attack, South Western Bell had buried the replacement lines underground and installed dummy wires to prevent further sabotage. It was only those dummy wires
另一首以节日为主题的诗暗示了露丝过去不光彩的性行为，写道：“……在那个阴郁的夜晚，灾难的预感让你疲惫。妓女在她的污泥床上背负着罪恶，因为她出卖身体却分文不取。与陌生人在邪恶的床上睡觉，愤怒的恶魔猎手看到了血是红色的。所有的婊子都应该对她们的名字和面孔保密。无助的本能被恶魔荡妇的威胁所释放。视线模糊，在控告者的笼子里受苦，脐带在愤怒中被种子连接。”1981年1月，芬利家的电话线第三次被切断。然而，在“诗人”之前的袭击之后，西南贝尔公司已经将更换的线路埋在地下，并安装了假电线以防止进一步的破坏。只有那些假电线
that were severed. In February, investigators set a trap for the poet by fitting Ruth with a bulletproof vest and letting her walk around to downtown Wichita accompanied by an undercover detective. The poet never appeared, but he wrote a letter after which read, I saw her Friday, but she was with some other female. This confirmed to detectives that the poet was observing Ruth in real time. in real time. In March, the poet threatened to kill Ruth on St. Patrick's Day. On April Fool's Day, he threw pieces of concrete at the Finley's house. By this point, police had investigated over 300 individuals amassing 14 large binders of information. Weeks were spent surveilling potential leads, examining criminal histories,
被切断了。二月，调查人员通过给露丝穿上防弹背心，并让她在一名便衣侦探的陪同下在威奇托市中心走动，为“诗人”设下了陷阱。那个“诗人”没有出现，但他随后写了一封信，上面写着：“我周五看到她了，但她和另一个女人在一起。”这向侦探们证实，“诗人”正在实时观察露丝。三月，“诗人”威胁要在圣帕特里克节杀死露丝。愚人节那天，他向芬利家扔了混凝土块。此时，警方已经调查了300多人，积累了14个大文件夹的信息。他们花了数周时间监视潜在的线索，检查犯罪记录，
and executing search warrants, yet all their efforts proved futile. Despite the significant time and resources invested, the police were left with nothing but the growing pile of anonymous letters. Ruth Finley kept all of the poet's letters stored in a notebook, telling the press, I wonder how long it takes him to write this crap. He doesn't do a bad job of writing poetry. Some of them are kind of funny. However, she admitted that the contents of some of the letters made her stomach ache, particularly the one sent at Christmas, which frightened her the most. Ed Finley said of the poet, I don't think he's crazy or insane. I'm sure he's a coward. He knows what he's doing, what the risks
并执行搜查令，但所有的努力都徒劳无功。尽管投入了大量的时间和资源，警方除了堆积如山的匿名信件外，一无所获。露丝·芬利把“诗人”所有的信件都存放在一个笔记本里，告诉媒体：“我不知道他写这些垃圾要花多长时间。他写诗写得还不错。有些甚至还有点好笑。”然而，她承认其中一些信件的内容让她感到胃痛，尤其是圣诞节寄来的那封，那是让她最害怕的一封。埃德·芬利谈到“诗人”时说：“我不认为他疯了或精神失常。我肯定他是个懦夫。他知道自己在做什么，知道风险
are. As time dragged on and the poet remained unidentified, Ruth's mental and emotional health spiralled. She confided in her sister that she felt as though she were coming out of her body, though she struggled to articulate what that meant. Ruth often spent hours staring blankly out of the windows of her home, disconnected from the world around her. The constant anxiety and fear left her body aching with persistent cramps and pains which she believed were physical manifestations of the overwhelming stress she was under. Ruth was also plagued by vivid nightmares. In one, she reached the top of a stairwell with the poet close behind her, only to find that the door at the top wouldn't open, allowing him to grab her. In another, she was surrounded by police
是什么。”随着时间流逝，“诗人”仍未被查明，露丝的精神和情绪健康状况急剧恶化。她向姐姐吐露，她感觉自己好像要灵魂出窍了，尽管她很难表达那意味着什么。露丝经常花几个小时呆滞地望着窗外，与周围的世界隔绝。持续的焦虑和恐惧使她的身体因持续的痉挛和疼痛而痛苦，她认为这是她所承受的巨大压力的身体表现。露丝还被生动的噩梦所困扰。在其中一个梦里，她到达楼梯顶端，“诗人”紧随其后，却发现顶部的门打不开，让他抓住了她。在另一个梦里，她被警察包围
but couldn't get their attention as the poet closed in. Panicking, Ruth ran into the street, only to be struck by a bus. There were also moments where Ruth's sense of reality seemed to slip. She could be going about her daily routine when she'd suddenly feel as though the world was spinning out of control. After one of these dizzying episodes, she woke up on the bathroom floor, disoriented and confused. Privately, Ruth had reached a breaking point and was planning to take her own life. On Wednesday October 1, 1981, just over four years after Ruth Finley's ordeal began, her husband Ed arrived at the Wichita Police Department headquarters with another letter from the poet. This one contained a poem resembling Shirley Locks, a piece penned by the still
却无法引起他们的注意，因为“诗人”正在逼近。惊慌失措的露丝跑向街道，却被一辆公共汽车撞倒。也有一些时刻，露丝的现实感似乎在滑落。她可能正在进行日常工作，突然感到世界在失控地旋转。在这些令人眩晕的事件之一后，她在浴室地板上醒来，感到迷茫和困惑。私下里，露丝已经到了崩溃的边缘，并计划结束自己的生命。1981年10月1日星期三，在露丝·芬利的磨难开始四年多后，她的丈夫埃德带着“诗人”的另一封信来到了威奇托警察局总部。这封信包含了一首类似于《雪莉·洛克斯》的诗，这是那个仍然
unidentified BTK Strangler in 1978. Ed intended to simply hand the letter over for the police's records and return to work, but instead he was escorted into an interview room. Confused and taken off guard, Ed was immediately read his rights. He was then questioned about his relationship with Ruth from their first meeting to the recent attacks. After he answered their questions, the detectives delivered a shocking statement. We know who the poet is, Ed. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at phys.ca. Give the perfect gift that keeps on giving. An Aura Frame. It's one that friends and family are sure to love and has been named the best digital photo frame by Wirecutter.
未被查明的BTK连环杀手在1978年创作的作品。埃德打算只是把信交给警方备案然后回去工作，但他却被带进了一间审讯室。埃德感到困惑和措手不及，立即被告知了他的权利。随后，他被问及与露丝的关系，从他们第一次见面到最近的袭击。在他回答了他们的问题后，侦探们发表了一份令人震惊的声明。“我们知道‘诗人’是谁了，埃德。”《案件档案》稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。今天就切换吧。条件适用。详情请访问phys.ca。赠送一份不断给予的完美礼物。Aura相框。这是朋友和家人一定会喜欢的礼物，并被Wirecutter评为最佳数码相框。
Aura Frames come with a vivid HD display, unlimited storage, and the ability to preload the frame with photos and videos. Right now you can get $25 off Aura's best-selling Carver Mac Frames by using promo code ACAST. Just visit AuraFrames.com. That's A-U-R-ver Mac Frames by using promo code ACAST. Just visit AuraFrames.com. That's A-U-R-A-Frames.com promo code ACAST. Conditions apply. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content." A few weeks earlier, a letter had arrived from the poet that differed from the others.
Aura相框配有生动的高清显示屏、无限存储空间，并能够预装照片和视频。现在，您可以使用促销代码ACAST购买Aura最畅销的Carver Mac相框，立减25美元。只需访问AuraFrames.com。那是A-U-R-A-Frames.com，促销代码ACAST。条件适用。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持《案件档案》继续提供高质量的内容。”几周前，一封来自“诗人”的信到了，它与其他的不同。
In it, he claimed that once he was finished with Ruth Finley, he would be turning his attention to a new target, the wife of Wichita's Chief of Police, Richard Lemunion. The letter included personal details about Chief Lemunion's wife, including the make and model of her car and the route she regularly drove home from the city. Normally, Chief Lemunyan adopted a hands-off approach, trusting his officers to manage their investigations independently. However, with the Poet case now striking close to home, he took the threat personally. Over the weekend, Chief Lemunyan immersed himself in the Poet's massive case file, meticulously combing through every little detail. By Sunday evening, he was convinced he had solved the case.
在信中，他声称一旦他处理完露丝·芬利，他就会把注意力转向一个新的目标，即威奇托警察局长理查德·勒穆尼恩的妻子。这封信包含了关于勒穆尼恩局长妻子的个人详细信息，包括她汽车的品牌和型号，以及她定期从城里回家的路线。通常，勒穆尼恩局长采取不干涉的态度，信任他的警官们独立管理他们的调查。然而，随着“诗人”案现在触及到他自己的家庭，他亲自处理了这个威胁。周末，勒穆尼恩局长沉浸在“诗人”庞大的案件档案中，一丝不苟地梳理每一个小细节。到周日晚上，他确信自己已经破案了。
Chief Lamanian held a confidential meeting with sixteen of his officers who had worked tirelessly on the Poe case over the years. Many of them had become personally acquainted with the Finleys, some even forming close friendships with Ruth and Ed beyond the confines of the investigation. By all accounts, the Finleys were warm, hospitable people who were deeply grateful for the dedication the police had shown in trying to bring their tormentor to justice. The only person in the room who hadn't met the Finleys was Chief Lemunyan himself. The officers sat in stunned silence as Chief Lemunyan presented his theory. He pointed out that the Finleys lived on a quiet, dead-end street, yet none of the neighbours
勒穆尼恩局长与十六名多年来在“诗人”案上不知疲倦工作的警官举行了一次机密会议。他们中的许多人已经与芬利夫妇相识，有些人甚至在调查范围之外与露丝和埃德建立了亲密的友谊。据所有人说，芬利夫妇是热情好客的人，他们对警方为将折磨他们的人绳之以法所做的奉献深表感激。房间里唯一没有见过芬利夫妇的人是勒穆尼恩局长本人。当勒穆尼恩局长提出他的理论时，警官们陷入了震惊的沉默。他指出，芬利夫妇住在一个安静的死胡同里，但没有一个邻居
or the police surveillance team had ever sighted anyone suspicious in the area when the poet struck. Similarly, there were no witnesses to the times Ruth had been confronted in public, despite these incidents occurring in heavily frequented areas. When the police installed the clandestine security camera in the Finley's backyard, the only other people who knew about it were Ruth and Dad. This raised the question of how the poet had managed to avoid it entirely. Moreover, the poet struck at the Finley's house when there wasn't a detective present to guard them. How did he always seem to know when the Finley's house when there wasn't a detective present to guard them. How did he always seem to know when the Finleys were unprotected? Whenever the couple went away for extended periods,
或警察监视小组在“诗人”袭击时在附近看到过任何可疑的人。同样，尽管这些事件发生在人流量大的地区，但在露丝在公共场合被对质时，也没有目击者。当警方在芬利家后院安装秘密安全摄像头时，唯一知道这件事的其他人是露丝和埃德。这就提出了一个问题：“诗人”是如何完全避开它的？此外，“诗人”在没有侦探保护的情况下袭击了芬利家。他怎么总是知道芬利夫妇什么时候没有受到保护？每当这对夫妇长时间外出时，
the poet's communications in the Eagle Beacons classified section immediately ceased, only to resume once the Finleys returned. When a new detective took over the case in 1980, he received a taunting letter from the poet. Yet, the Finleys were the only ones who knew about the change in leadership at the time. As for the November 1978 abduction, there were inconsistencies in Ruth's story, such as the time the attack took place. She also described the backseat of the Bel Air as being filled with random farmyard junk, including gas cans and chunks of concrete. But as Chief Lemunyan pointed out, if the car was packed with such items, how could two people fit in the backseat? Ruth claimed that one of the captors
“诗人”在《鹰信报》分类广告栏里的通讯就会立即停止，直到芬利夫妇回来才恢复。当一名新侦探在1980年接手此案时，他收到了“诗人”的一封嘲讽信。然而，当时只有芬利夫妇知道领导层的变动。至于1978年11月的绑架案，露丝的故事中存在不一致之处，例如袭击发生的时间。她还描述了别克汽车的后座上堆满了随机的农场垃圾，包括油桶和混凝土块。但正如勒穆尼恩局长指出的那样，如果车里塞满了这些物品，两个人怎么能挤进后座呢？露丝声称其中一名绑架者
had chased her through the muddy park, yet when police examined the park, only one set of footprints were uncovered. Ruth's. Ruth claimed to have been struck in the face with a piece of concrete during the attack, but she had no injuries consistent with such a blow. As for the stabbing attack, Ruth said she rolled up her car window after fighting her way into the car, yet the door had been locked when she arrived. Chief Lemunion found it strange that she had left her car locked but with the window down. To him, nothing about the case made sense. Chief Lemunyan announced to the group, the poet is Ruth Finley herself. The claim flew in the face of everything the case detectives believed, as well as the information
在泥泞的公园里追赶她，但当警察检查公园时，只发现了一组脚印。露丝的。露丝声称在袭击中被一块混凝土击中脸部，但她没有任何与这种打击相符的伤痕。至于刺伤袭击，露丝说她在挣扎着进入车内后摇上了车窗，但她到达时车门是锁着的。勒穆尼恩局长觉得奇怪的是，她把车锁上了，但窗户却开着。对他来说，这个案子的一切都说不通。勒穆尼恩局长向小组宣布：“‘诗人’就是露丝·芬利本人。”这一说法与案件侦探们所相信的一切，以及从
gathered from medical personnel and other experts. Doctors were certain Ruth couldn't have stabbed herself. Chief Lemunyan disagreed. He insisted that Ruth had inflicted the wounds on herself, and everything else about the situation had been fabricated. He felt the same way about the abduction and all the other acts attributed to the poet. Chief Lemunyan sensed the other detectives' incredulity and reluctance to accept his theory. What he was suggesting contradicted everything they knew about the Finleys.
医务人员和其他专家那里收集到的信息背道而驰。医生们确信露丝不可能刺伤自己。勒穆尼恩局长不同意。他坚持认为露丝是自残，关于这种情况的其他一切都是捏造的。他对绑架案和所有其他归咎于“诗人”的行为也有同样的感觉。勒穆尼恩局长感觉到了其他侦探的怀疑和不愿接受他的理论。他所暗示的内容与他们所知道的关于芬利夫妇的一切相矛盾。
What he was suggesting contradicted everything they knew about the Finleys. Ruth was neither unstable nor attention seeking, she was modest and gentle, and her distress seemed undeniably genuine. Chief Lemunyan believed he could view Ruth with suspicion because he'd examined the case file objectively without biases that might come from knowing her personally. Chief Lemonyan proposed 24-hour covert surveillance of the Finleys starting that very night. While the other detectives remained uncertain about his assertions, they ultimately agreed to his plan. On Thursday September 17, Ruth and Ed Finley drove to East Gate Mall, oblivious to the fact that they were being tailed by an unmarked police car. Ed pulled into the mall's parking lot and stopped at a mailbox. Ruth got out and deposited several letters before returning to the vehicle.
他所暗示的内容与他们所知道的关于芬利夫妇的一切相矛盾。露丝既不稳定也不寻求关注，她谦虚而温柔，她的痛苦似乎无可置疑地真实。勒穆尼恩局长认为他可以怀疑露丝，因为他客观地检查了案件档案，没有因为私下认识她而产生的偏见。勒穆尼恩局长提议从当晚开始对芬利夫妇进行24小时秘密监视。虽然其他侦探对他的断言仍不确定，但他们最终同意了他的计划。9月17日星期四，露丝和埃德·芬利开车前往东门购物中心，完全不知道他们正被一辆无标志的警车跟踪。埃德把车开进购物中心的停车场，停在一个邮箱旁。露丝下车投递了几封信，然后回到车里。
After the Finleys drove off, officers converged on the mailbox and retrieved five letters that Ruth had mailed. Three were identified as personal business or private correspondence. One was addressed to a police reporter at a local television station, and the final one was addressed to Ruth herself. Both of these letters were from the poet and featured his unmistakable handwriting. The one to Ruth was written in the style of the children's poem Hickory Dickory Dock and referenced her attack in 1946. Hickory Dickory Dock, the name on this face, is Smock. Heat the iron for the brand.
在芬利夫妇开车离开后，警官们聚集在邮箱旁，取回了露丝寄出的五封信。三封被确定为个人业务或私人信件。一封寄给当地电视台的警务记者，最后一封寄给露丝自己。这两封信都来自“诗人”，并带有他那无法辨认的笔迹。寄给露丝的那封信是以童谣《Hickory Dickory Dock》的风格写的，并提到了她1946年的袭击事件。“Hickory Dickory Dock，这张脸上的名字是Smock。加热烙铁进行烙印。
Co-operate for games planned. Hickory Dickory Dock. The next day, Ed and Ruth continued with their normal routine. Then on Saturday, Ed drove Ruth to Eastgate Mall once again. This time, she deposited four more letters, another of which was addressed to herself from the poet. Dark-eyed bitch sat all alone, near the river and tied to a stone. Sink in the water and in fear. Call for help and no one's near. Weep no more. The race is run. You lost the battle, and I have won." A search of Ruth's office at South Western Bell uncovered a book of prose and poetry, a swatch of red bandana, and a sheet of carbon paper bearing the poet's handwriting.
配合计划好的游戏。Hickory Dickory Dock。”第二天，埃德和露丝继续他们的正常生活。然后周六，埃德再次开车送露丝去东门购物中心。这一次，她又投递了四封信，其中一封又是“诗人”寄给她自己的。“黑眼睛的婊子独自坐着，靠近河边，被绑在石头上。沉入水中，充满恐惧。呼救却无人靠近。别再哭了。比赛结束了。你输了这场战斗，而我赢了。”对露丝在西南贝尔公司办公室的搜查发现了一本散文和诗集、一块红头巾碎片，以及一张带有“诗人”笔迹的复写纸。
It was not uncommon for the poet to send an original letter to the Finleys and a carbon copy of the same letter to the police. For Chief Richard Lemunyan, these discoveries vindicated his controversial belief that Ruth Finley was indeed the poet. However, the question of what role, if any, Ed Finley played in the scheme lingered. When Ed arrived at the Wichita Police Department headquarters on Wednesday October 1 1981 to hand over the Shirley Locks-style letter from the poet, he was led into an interview room and asked several questions about his wife and their recent experiences. Afterwards, Ed was hit with a bombshell.
“诗人”给芬利夫妇寄一封原件信，并给警方寄同一封信的复写副本，这并不罕见。对于理查德·勒穆尼恩局长来说，这些发现证实了他那具有争议的信念，即露丝·芬利确实就是“诗人”。然而，埃德·芬利在这个计划中扮演了什么角色（如果有的话）的问题仍然存在。当埃德于1981年10月1日星期三来到威奇托警察局总部递交“诗人”那封《雪莉·洛克斯》风格的信时，他被带进了一间审讯室，并被问及关于他妻子和他们最近经历的几个问题。事后，埃德遭到了重磅炸弹的打击。
The detectives knew who the poet was. Ed stared at them, processing the statement, before responding, statement before responding, I hope the hell you do, let's go get him then. But the detectives had other plans. They showed Ed some photographs, the first of which was a candid shot of Ruth as she mailed letters at the East Gate Mall. The detectives told Ed they'd caught Ruth mailing five letters from the poet in the past two weeks. "'The poet is Ruth,' they told him matter-of-factly." Ed seemingly couldn't believe what he was hearing. He repeatedly muttered, "'Oh my God,' as the detectives informed him of all the evidence they'd uncovered in Ruth's office. Ed agreed to take a lie detector test to eliminate himself from the investigation.
侦探们知道“诗人”是谁。埃德盯着他们，消化着这句话，然后回答道：“我真希望你们知道，那我们去抓他吧。”但侦探们有别的计划。他们给埃德看了几张照片，第一张是露丝在东门购物中心寄信时的抓拍照片。侦探们告诉埃德，他们抓到露丝在过去两周内寄出了五封“诗人”的信。“‘诗人’就是露丝，”他们客观地告诉他。埃德似乎无法相信他所听到的。当侦探们告诉他他们在露丝办公室发现的所有证据时，他反复嘟囔着：“噢，我的上帝。”埃德同意接受测谎仪测试，以将自己排除在调查之外。
During the test, he firmly denied knowing that Ruth was the poet, or helping her carry out the scheme. The examiner found that Ed was telling the truth, and Chief Lemunyan agreed. After conducting his extensive research into the case, Chief Lemunyan was confident that Ruth had acted alone. A search of the Finley home uncovered another book of poetry, more pieces of carbon paper and scraps of red bandana. Meanwhile, detectives approached Ruth at work and requested she come to the station under the pretense of looking at mugshots of potential poet suspects. Ruth happily agreed. She arrived at the station and cheerfully greeted officers there, asking how they were and flashing her trademark kind smile. She was then
在测试过程中，他坚定地否认知道露丝就是“诗人”，或者帮助她执行这个计划。检查员发现埃德说的是实话，勒穆尼恩局长也表示同意。在对案件进行了广泛的研究后，勒穆尼恩局长确信露丝是独自行动的。对芬利家的搜查发现了另一本诗集、更多的复写纸碎片和红头巾碎片。与此同时，侦探们在工作中接近露丝，并要求她以查看潜在“诗人”嫌疑人照片为借口来到警察局。露丝愉快地同意了。她到达警察局，兴高采烈地问候那里的警官，询问他们过得怎么样，并露出了她标志性的亲切微笑。她随后被
led into an interview room. The detectives informed Ruth that they were about to ask her some tough questions, starting with the 1946 attack in Fort Scott. As they worked their way up to the stabbing incident of 1976, the detective's tone shifted, becoming more pointed and accusatory. Sensing the change in atmosphere, Ruth's smile faded. She slumped in her seat, her expression turning cold. Have you ever written any of the poet's letters? the detective asked point blank. Have you ever written any of the poet's letters?" the detective asked point blank. No, sir, Ruth replied staunchly. The detective pressed on. What if I told you I have evidence that shows you did? It's time to come clean.
带进了一间审讯室。侦探们告诉露丝，他们要问她一些棘手的问题，从1946年发生在斯科特堡的袭击开始。当他们谈到1976年的刺伤事件时，侦探的语气发生了变化，变得更加尖锐和具有指控性。感觉到气氛的变化，露丝的笑容消失了。她瘫坐在座位上，表情变得冰冷。“你写过任何‘诗人’的信吗？”侦探直截了当地问。“你写过任何‘诗人’的信吗？”侦探直截了当地问。不，先生，露丝坚定地回答。侦探继续追问。如果我告诉你我有证据表明你写了呢？是时候坦白了。
Ruth appeared puzzled and struggled to respond. The detectives weren't convinced. They asked Ruth, do you want to keep playing your game? Telling her, you got a problem, lady. Ruth seems confused. When did I mail those letters? She asked softly. The detectives showed her the photos they took of her at the East Gate Mall. Ruth shook her head, refusing to meet their eyes as tears began to well. "'Do you need help?' the detective asked gently. In a quiet voice, Ruth responded, "'Yes.'" In a quiet voice, Ruth responded, yes. Ruth gradually admitted she was responsible for all of the incidents attributed to the poet, except for setting fire to the Christmas wreath on her front door. The abduction in 1978 had never happened either. In reality, Ruth had taken the bus to the park where she planted her coat and shoes and staged the scene of her escape. She based the description of her abductor on an
露丝显得很困惑，难以回答。侦探们并不相信。他们问露丝：“你想继续玩你的游戏吗？”并告诉她：“你摊上事了，女士。”露丝似乎很困惑。“我什么时候寄了那些信？”她轻声问道。侦探们给她看了他们在东门购物中心拍她的照片。露丝摇了摇头，拒绝与他们对视，泪水开始涌出。“你需要帮助吗？”侦探温柔地问。露丝用微弱的声音回答：“是的。”露丝逐渐承认她对归咎于“诗人”的所有事件负责，除了点燃她前门上的圣诞花环。1978年的绑架案也从未发生过。实际上，露丝乘公共汽车去了公园，在那里她放下了外套和鞋子，并伪造了她逃跑的现场。她根据一个
unrelated man who once stopped her on the street. As for the stabbing, Ruth admitted that was a lie too, but she claimed to have no recollection of it whatsoever. When asked why she made the whole thing up, Ruth buried her head in her hands and responded, I don't know. Ruth claimed she couldn't remember what was going through her mind when she wrote the letters from the poet. Regarding the single letter sent from Oklahoma City, she explained that she had mailed it directly to the post office there, requesting that they forward it back to Wichita. Detectives didn't even know such a scenario was possible.
曾经在街上拦住她的无关男子的描述来描述她的绑架者。至于刺伤，露丝承认那也是谎言，但她声称对此完全没有记忆。当被问及为什么要编造这一切时，露丝把头埋在手里回答道：“我不知道。”露丝声称她不记得当她写下“诗人”的信时，她的脑子里在想什么。关于那封从俄克拉荷马城寄出的唯一一封信，她解释说她直接把它寄到了那里的邮局，要求他们把它转发回威奇托。侦探们甚至不知道这种情况是可能的。
They remained perplexed as to why Ruth had gone to such lengths to manipulate those around her, and she seemed equally puzzled. She denied ever wanting the publicity that came with her ordeal, and could offer no explanation as to why she had done it. When asked if Ed was involved, Ruth firmly replied, absolutely not. She maintained that he had always been a good husband and that he'd done nothing to influence her behaviour. Detectives worked to uncover more information about Ruth's scheme, but she only gave vague responses. In an effort to reassure her, the detectives said there were no hard feelings between them.
他们仍然感到困惑，为什么露丝会费尽心思去操纵周围的人，而她自己似乎也同样感到困惑。她否认自己曾想要因这段经历而获得关注，也无法解释自己为什么要这样做。当被问及埃德是否参与其中时，露丝坚定地回答，绝对没有。她坚持认为他一直是个好丈夫，并没有做任何影响她行为的事情。侦探们试图挖掘更多关于露丝计划的信息，但她只给出了模糊的回应。为了安抚她，侦探们表示他们之间并没有任何芥蒂。
There should be, Ruth replied quietly. When asked how she felt, Ruth admitted, I wish I was dead. A doctor arrived to assess Ruth, but he was unable to provide a clear explanation for her behaviour either. I guess I am just crazy, Ruth told him sadly. She was subsequently admitted to the hospital for a psychiatric evaluation, where she said she remembered some flashes of things, such as writing a letter while seated next to her washing machine. Overall though, Ruth could recall very little about her time as the poet. Regardless, she maintained that her actions hadn't been willful and that something else entirely was at play. Ruth was eventually deemed stable enough
露丝平静地回答说，应该有的。当被问及感受时，露丝承认，我希望我死了。一位医生赶来评估露丝的情况，但他同样无法对她的行为给出明确的解释。露丝难过地告诉他，我想我只是疯了。随后她被送进医院接受精神评估，在那里她说自己记得一些零星的片段，比如坐在洗衣机旁写信。但总的来说，露丝对她作为“诗人”的那段时光几乎没有什么记忆。无论如何，她坚持认为自己的行为并非出于主观意愿，而是有其他因素在起作用。露丝最终被认为情况稳定，
to return home, though she continued to work with a psychiatrist named Dr. Andrew Pickens to better understand herself and her actions. During one of their therapy sessions, Ruth broke down in tears as she grappled with the profound humiliation of her deception being exposed. She referred to herself as a bad person before suddenly composing herself and saying, I'm a bad little girl for crying. This moment sparked a crucial conversation with Dr. Pickens about the deep shame Ruth felt whenever she expressed emotions. She traced this shame back to her mother's dismissive attitude toward her feelings during childhood. Ruth had initially described her mother with reverence, remembering her as strong,
可以回家了，尽管她继续与一位名叫安德鲁·皮肯斯博士的精神科医生合作，以更好地了解自己和自己的行为。在一次治疗中，露丝在面对自己的欺骗行为被揭露所带来的深刻羞辱时，崩溃大哭。她称自己是个坏人，随后突然镇定下来，说道：“我是个因为哭泣而变坏的小女孩。”这一时刻引发了她与皮肯斯博士之间关于露丝在表达情感时所感受到的深层羞耻感的重要对话。她将这种羞耻感追溯到童年时期母亲对她情感的漠视态度。露丝最初怀着崇敬的心情描述她的母亲，记得她坚强、
confident and flawless, an ideal she admired and sought to emulate. But as Dr. Pickens gently guided Ruth through her feelings, it became clear that she held conflicting emotions. Ruth had been told she was an unplanned pregnancy, one that led to a difficult birth that traumatised her mother, who then developed a drinking problem. Her parents also expressed a disappointment that she hadn't been born a boy, and Ruth felt her mother favoured her sister. Sex was a forbidden topic in the Smock household, and whenever Ruth expressed curiosity, her staunchly religious mother would snap. Why do you have to talk this filth?
自信且完美无瑕，这是她所钦佩并试图效仿的理想形象。但随着皮肯斯博士温柔地引导露丝梳理她的感受，很明显她内心存在着矛盾的情绪。露丝曾被告知她是一个意外怀孕的孩子，这次艰难的生产让她的母亲受到了创伤，随后母亲便染上了酗酒的毛病。她的父母也曾表示对她不是男孩感到失望，露丝觉得母亲更偏爱她的姐姐。在斯莫克家中，性是一个禁忌话题，每当露丝表现出好奇时，她那虔诚的母亲就会厉声呵斥：“你为什么要谈论这些肮脏的东西？”
When speaking with Dr Pickens, Ruth often apologised for any negative comments about her mother, before recounting more positive memories. During a therapy session, Ruth recalled an uncomfortable childhood memory of sitting naked on someone's lap. She couldn't remember who it was, but the thought made her feel terrible. She broke into tears before quickly dismissing the memory, saying, It's not right to cry. It took time for Ruth to open up about her negative feelings toward crying and expressing emotions. She eventually admitted that as a child she was very clinginging and emotional, which she believed embarrassed her mother.
在与皮肯斯博士交谈时，露丝经常为自己对母亲的负面评价道歉，随后又会讲述一些更积极的回忆。在一次治疗中，露丝回忆起童年时一个不舒服的记忆：赤身裸体地坐在某人的膝盖上。她记不起那是谁，但这个想法让她感到非常糟糕。她泪流满面，随后迅速打断了这个记忆，说：“哭是不对的。”露丝花了一些时间才敞开心扉谈论她对哭泣和表达情感的负面感受。她最终承认，小时候她非常粘人且情绪化，她认为这让她的母亲感到尴尬。
Dr. Pickens understood that clingingness in children often stems from overprotective parenting or from feeling rejected by caregivers. In Ruth's case, he believed her mother fell into the latter category. Whenever Ruth cried, her mother scolded her, saying it made her look ugly. Ruth recalled how her mother displayed an unflattering photo of a child screaming in a picture frame at home, claiming it was a picture of Ruth herself. What a big crybaby you are, her mother would say. Ruth later realised that the photo wasn't of her at all, but her random child clipped from a magazine. Ruth also remembered an incident from her childhood where a man took her into a room
皮肯斯博士明白，孩子的粘人通常源于过度保护的教养方式，或者感到被照顾者拒绝。在露丝的案例中，他认为她的母亲属于后者。每当露丝哭泣时，母亲就会责骂她，说这让她看起来很丑。露丝回忆起母亲在家里相框里展示了一张孩子尖叫的丑陋照片，声称那是露丝本人的照片。母亲会说：“你真是个爱哭鬼。”露丝后来意识到那张照片根本不是她，而是从杂志上剪下来的随机小孩。露丝还记得童年时期发生的一件事，一个男人把她带进一个房间，
and tied her to a bed. Though she couldn't remember what happened next, she vividly recalled the fear she felt, sobbing in the dark until the man untied her and let her go. When Ruth later told her parents about the ordeal, they showed no concern and were instead irritated by her crying. When Dr. Pickens asked how she felt about this incident as an adult, Ruth starkly replied, I don't have any feelings about it. But as therapy progressed, Ruth began to express anger at her parents' lack of care. That poor little girl, she said aloud, why didn't her parents do something? poor little girl," she said aloud. Why didn't her parents do something? Yet, she quickly blames herself, saying her parents were right and that she shouldn't
把她绑在床上。虽然她记不起接下来发生了什么，但她清晰地记得那种恐惧感，在黑暗中啜泣，直到那个男人解开绳子让她离开。当露丝后来把这段经历告诉父母时，他们并没有表现出关心，反而对她的哭泣感到恼火。当皮肯斯博士问她成年后对这件事有什么感觉时，露丝冷冷地回答：“我对此没有任何感觉。”但随着治疗的深入，露丝开始对父母缺乏关爱感到愤怒。她大声说：“那个可怜的小女孩，为什么她的父母什么都不做？”然而，她很快又责怪自己，说父母是对的，她不应该
have cried. It was determined that Ruth had used repression since childhood to bury what she had been taught were unacceptable feelings, hiding her true emotions and needs behind a mask of being agreeable. Over time, Ruth unlocked more repressed memories until she came to the painful realisation that she had been the victim of severe childhood sexual abuse. The perpetrator was an adult neighbour, with most of the abuse taking place in a barn near her family's farm.
哭泣。经判定，露丝自童年起就使用压抑机制来掩盖那些被教导为不可接受的情感，将她真实的情绪和需求隐藏在随和的面具之下。随着时间的推移，露丝解开了更多被压抑的记忆，直到她痛苦地意识到自己曾是严重童年性虐待的受害者。施暴者是一位成年邻居，大部分虐待发生在离她家农场不远的一个谷仓里。
During each attack, Ruth was filled with fear and often cried, which angered her abuser. He threatened to put her in a sack and throw her into a river if she told anyone. Terrified, Ruth stayed silent. When her parents noticed her distress, they called her a crybaby instead of offering support or trying to understand the cause. Ruth blocked out these painful memories, only confronting them years later in therapy. At the time, recovered memory therapy was a popular form of psychotherapy. It is worth noting, however, that it has since been widely discredited, and its legitimacy remains up for debate among clinical and legal professionals. Recovered memory therapy is no longer recommended by professional mental health associations, as evidence has shown it can
在每次袭击中，露丝都充满了恐惧，经常哭泣，这激怒了施暴者。他威胁说，如果她告诉任何人，就把她装进麻袋扔进河里。露丝吓坏了，保持沉默。当父母注意到她的痛苦时，他们称她为爱哭鬼，而不是提供支持或试图了解原因。露丝屏蔽了这些痛苦的记忆，直到多年后在治疗中才面对它们。当时，“记忆恢复疗法”是一种流行的心理治疗形式。然而值得注意的是，它后来已被广泛否定，其合法性在临床和法律专业人士中仍有争议。专业心理健康协会不再推荐记忆恢复疗法，因为证据表明它可能
result in patients developing false memories. Ruth told Dr. Pickens that during the abuse, she would envision a beautiful young girl like a guardian angel who distracted and comforted her. Dr. Pickens believed this was an early sign of Ruth disassociating from reality during trauma. He also believed that the poet was another psychological manifestation born from trauma. The poet first appeared the night of Ed Finley's suspected heart attack in 1977. The presence of the BTK Strangler in Wichita at the time likely contributed, as his crimes resembled Ruth's childhood abuse. Like the Guardian Angel from her childhood, the poet felt very real to Ruth. However, unlike the Angel, he appeared as a figure to punish her,
导致患者产生虚假记忆。露丝告诉皮肯斯博士，在遭受虐待期间，她会想象一个像守护天使一样美丽的年轻女孩，她会分散她的注意力并安慰她。皮肯斯博士认为这是露丝在创伤期间与现实解离的早期迹象。他还认为，“诗人”是源于创伤的另一种心理表现。诗人第一次出现是在1977年埃德·芬利疑似心脏病发作的那天晚上。当时威奇托市“BTK连环杀手”的存在可能加剧了这种情况，因为他的罪行与露丝童年受到的虐待相似。就像她童年时代的守护天使一样，诗人对露丝来说感觉非常真实。然而，与天使不同的是，他作为一个惩罚她的形象出现，
embodying her repressed guilt and anger. Elements tied to the poet, such as the red bandana, chunks of concrete, and the bridge over the river, were connected to the man who had abused her. One of the earliest memories Ruth could recall hinted at why her punisher took on the identity of a poet. One day, while flipping through a cherished book of children's poems, something strange happened. The familiar rhymes like Hickory Dickory Dock and Mary Had a Little Lamb were replaced by dark, unsettling verses that told Ruth she was a bad little girl. The poems frightened her so deeply that she hid the book away and never opened it again. Ruth was ultimately diagnosed with atypical impulse disorder with the disassociative and
体现了她被压抑的内疚和愤怒。与诗人相关的元素，如红头巾、混凝土块和河上的桥，都与那个虐待她的男人有关。露丝能回忆起的最早记忆之一暗示了为什么她的惩罚者会以诗人的身份出现。有一天，当她翻阅一本珍爱的童诗集时，奇怪的事情发生了。熟悉的童谣，如《Hickory Dickory Dock》和《Mary Had a Little Lamb》，被黑暗、令人不安的诗句所取代，告诉露丝她是个坏女孩。这些诗让她感到非常恐惧，以至于她把书藏了起来，再也没有打开过。露丝最终被诊断出患有非典型冲动障碍，伴有解离和
depressive features, a condition marked by sudden temporary changes in consciousness, identity or motor behaviour. This can cause memory loss, confusion about one's identity, or a distorted sense of reality. In hindsight, the connection between the poet and Ruth was clear. One letter stated, A fucked up childhood causes anger and hate, while another described, childhood causes anger and hate, while another described, Two fiends housed in a throbbing head, one with fumbling and weakened grasp, winning one tightened to the rope's strangling clasp. The poet also wrote that it felt like people were exploding to get out of his head.
抑郁特征，这是一种以意识、身份或运动行为突然暂时改变为标志的疾病。这可能导致记忆丧失、身份认同混乱或现实感扭曲。事后看来，诗人与露丝之间的联系显而易见。一封信写道：“糟糕的童年导致愤怒和仇恨”，而另一封信则描述道：“两个恶魔住在悸动的头颅里，一个笨拙而无力，另一个紧紧抓着绳索的绞索。”诗人还写道，感觉就像有人在脑子里爆炸一样。
In another letter, he asserted, out of his head. In another letter, he asserted, Dear Ruth, the game is over. The players are dead. I can play any part, coming out of my head. Blunder on and win the fight, stealthily unquestioned, day or night. Ruth claimed to remember nothing about the stabbing incident at Town East Mall. As part of her recovery, she returned to the scene and envisioned snakes writhing on the parking lot ground. Over time, through therapy, her memories of that day became clearer. She recalled hearing the words, you have to do it, as she looked down at a knife in her
在另一封信中，他断言：“亲爱的露丝，游戏结束了。玩家们都死了。我可以扮演任何角色，从我的脑海中走出来。跌跌撞撞地赢得战斗，悄无声息，无论昼夜。”露丝声称对镇东购物中心的刺伤事件毫无记忆。作为康复的一部分，她回到了现场，想象停车场地面上有蛇在蠕动。随着时间的推移，通过治疗，她对那一天的记忆变得清晰起来。她回忆起当她低头看着手中的刀时，听到了“你必须这样做”的话，
hands before stabbing herself. Ruth accepted that the axe she had attributed to the poet were either fabricated or committed by her. However, her unreliable memories left many questions about what was real. She maintained that the 1946 attack in her Fort's God apartment had happened and that the burns on her thighs were caused by an intruder, though some questioned the truth of these claims. Despite the uncertainty, the realisation that she and the poet were the same person brought Ruth a sense of wholeness. Still, she feared he might resurface and take control again if she experienced further trauma. The poet's dark verses continued to surface in Ruth's mind, though they now focused on her unloving mother and childhood abuse.
然后刺伤了自己。露丝承认她归咎于诗人的斧头袭击要么是捏造的，要么是她自己所为。然而，她不可靠的记忆留下了许多关于什么是真实的疑问。她坚持认为1946年她在福特戈德公寓的袭击事件确实发生过，大腿上的烧伤是入侵者造成的，尽管有些人质疑这些说法的真实性。尽管存在不确定性，但意识到她和诗人是同一个人，给露丝带来了一种完整感。尽管如此，她仍然担心如果再次经历创伤，他可能会卷土重来并再次控制她。诗人的黑暗诗句继续在露丝的脑海中浮现，尽管它们现在集中在她那冷漠的母亲和童年虐待上。
Ruth would sit at her table, letting the words flow onto paper without consciously thinking about them. Sometimes these poems exceeded 2,000 words. She brought them to therapy, reading them aloud and discovering their content for the first time. This process provided insight into how she had written as the poet without remembering it. At first, the poems were incredibly dark and self-critical. A little girl alone in tears, the worst person born in years. I don't have a mother, I am not born. No one upset, and she's not forlorn." In time, however, the poems began to reflect feelings of self-forgiveness and a readiness to heal. One read, "...a child was born, but was not anywhere. She wanted you to find her, she was so sad, she wished you would not think of her as bad. She searched for you but then she knew,
露丝会坐在桌边，让文字流淌在纸上，而不去有意识地思考它们。有时这些诗超过2000字。她把它们带到治疗中，大声朗读，第一次发现它们的内容。这个过程让她深入了解了自己是如何在不记得的情况下以诗人的身份写作的。起初，这些诗非常黑暗且充满自我批评。“一个小女孩独自哭泣，多年来最糟糕的人出生了。我没有母亲，我没有出生。没有人难过，她也不孤单。”然而，随着时间的推移，这些诗开始反映出自我宽恕和准备治愈的感觉。其中一首写道：“……一个孩子出生了，但无处可去。她想让你找到她，她太难过了，她希望你不要认为她很坏。她寻找你，但后来她知道了，
her childish ways, it was time she outgrew. But just the same I dread the day, when I remain and you fade away." In total, the Wichita police had spent over $370,000 investigating the poet, the equivalent of over a million dollars today. After reviewing Ruth Finley's psychiatric reports, authorities found no evidence of malicious intent and concluded that she wasn't a threat to the community, only to herself. Prosecutors decided not to press charges. After six years of therapy, Ruth worked to repair her reputation in Wichita. Outraged locals misunderstood the context, believing she had acted intentionally. Ruth was initially reluctant to speak publicly about her
她孩子气的行为，是时候长大了。但同样地，我害怕那一天，当我留下而你消失。”总共，威奇托警方花费了超过37万美元调查诗人，相当于今天的100多万美元。在审查了露丝·芬利的精神病报告后，当局没有发现恶意意图的证据，并得出结论，她对社区没有威胁，只对自己有威胁。检察官决定不起诉。经过六年的治疗，露丝努力修复她在威奇托的声誉。愤怒的当地人误解了背景，认为她是故意为之。露丝最初不愿公开谈论她的
childhood trauma, but agreed to a televised interview for the local news accompanied by her therapist, Dr Andrew Pickens. In the interview, Dr. Pickens expressed his belief that the poet no longer existed, a sentiment Ruth shared. Following the broadcast, Ruth received overwhelming support. It inspired many people to share their own stories of childhood abuse for the first time. Ruth publicly thanked everyone who had helped her during the four years she had been taunted by the poet, including the doctors and nurses who treated her, and her family, who continued to stand by her. She expressed immense gratitude to the officers of the Wichita Police Department, saying, "...in the end, they saved me from either a mental breakdown
童年创伤，但同意在她的治疗师安德鲁·皮肯斯博士的陪同下接受当地新闻的电视采访。在采访中，皮肯斯博士表示他相信诗人已不复存在，露丝也持同样的观点。节目播出后，露丝获得了压倒性的支持。这激励了许多人第一次分享他们自己的童年虐待故事。露丝公开感谢了在诗人嘲弄她的四年里帮助过她的每一个人，包括治疗她的医生和护士，以及一直支持她的家人。她向威奇托警察局的警官们表达了极大的感激，说：“……最终，他们把我从精神崩溃
or my own self-destruction." Ruth later shared her experience with author Jean Stone, who released an in-depth book on the case titled, Little Girl Fly Away, with additional input from Dr Pickens. In 2024, a film based on Ruth's story, The Killer Inside, The Ruth Finley Story, was released. Ed Finley remained unwaveringly supportive of his wife, even after learning the truth. They went on to live a stable and happy life together. Ruth Finley dedicated her life to advocating for mental health awareness and encouraging others to seek therapy. She also learned to write Braille and volunteered for the Braille Association of Kansas, manually transcribing textbooks for people with vision
或自我毁灭中拯救了出来。”露丝后来与作家简·斯通分享了她的经历，后者发布了一本关于此案的深度书籍，名为《小女孩飞走》，并得到了皮肯斯博士的额外投入。2024年，一部基于露丝故事的电影《内在的杀手：露丝·芬利的故事》上映。埃德·芬利即使在得知真相后，依然坚定地支持他的妻子。他们继续过着稳定而幸福的生活。露丝·芬利致力于倡导心理健康意识，并鼓励他人寻求治疗。她还学习了盲文，并为堪萨斯州盲文协会做志愿者，为视障人士手动转录教科书。
impairments. A lover of needlework and knitting, she donated handmade hats and scarves to US troops in Afghanistan. Ruth passed away in May 2019 at the age of 89. During her final therapy session with Dr Andrew Pickens, Ruth read a poem she'd written for the occasion. Thank you for helping me see as a goal, having the little girl melted into me and being whole. I can't be rescued except in my mind, but that's only possible because you have been so kind. My heart feels it might break on this sad day as I leave here and you go away. But my heart is also happy inside, that I gained my freedom and also some pride. In my mind when the need may arise, I'll be with you and I'll shut my eyes. In my heart, your spot will always be there, close to a little girl who felt you did care."
她热爱针线活和编织，向阿富汗的美军捐赠了手工制作的帽子和围巾。露丝于2019年5月去世，享年89岁。在与安德鲁·皮肯斯博士的最后一次治疗中，露丝读了一首她为这次场合写的诗。“感谢你帮助我看到目标，让那个小女孩融入我，变得完整。除了在我的脑海里，我无法被拯救，但这只有在你如此善良的情况下才有可能。在这个悲伤的日子里，当我离开这里，你走开时，我的心感觉可能会碎。但我的心在里面也很高兴，因为我获得了自由，也获得了一些自豪。在我的脑海里，当需要出现时，我会和你在一起，我会闭上眼睛。在我的心里，你的位置将永远在那里，靠近一个觉得你确实关心她的小女孩。”
After that, Ruth never wrote another poem again. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Dr. Jordan B. Peterson. An evening to transform your life. If you say the truth and nothing else, you'll have an immense adventure as a consequence. You won't know what's going to happen to you, but the truth will reveal the world the way it's intended to be revealed, and the consequence for you will be that you'll have the adventure of your life.
在那之后，露丝再也没有写过诗。有了Fizz忠诚计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。你知道，就是发短信之类的。如果你没有通过移动套餐获得额外数据和美元折扣等奖励，那你就不在Fizz。今天就切换吧。条件适用。详情请访问fizz.ca。乔丹·B·彼得森博士。一个改变你生活的夜晚。如果你说真话，除此之外别无他求，你将经历一场巨大的冒险。你不会知道会发生什么，但真相会以它本应被揭示的方式揭示世界，而对你来说，结果就是你将拥有你一生中最伟大的冒险。
Live at Scotiabank Arena, March 6th. Get tickets now at LiveNation.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
3月6日在丰业银行体育馆现场直播。现在就在LiveNation.com购票。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。